Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße endlich wieder alle hier an den Hörgeräten,
denn, ja, die lange Corona-Pause ist jetzt erst mal vorbei
und es gilt mal wieder, neue Themenwelten zu erforschen.
Und heute wollen wir mal ein bisschen mit der Metaebene einsteigen
und uns über Wissenschaft oder vielmehr über Wissen unterhalten
und was das Wissen denn so bewirken kann
und vor allem, wie man das Wissen unter das Volk bringt.
Und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich den Ralph, Ralph Caspers.
Hallo, hallo Tim.
Ich mag übrigens total den Frankenstein Mission Impossible Vibe von dem Vorspann, von der Musik.
Frankenstein Mission Impossible Vibe, okay ja, ist so ein bisschen die akustische Zusammenfassung der Wissenschaftsgeschichte.
Ja.
Ist alles drin irgendwie, vom Stein über Holz bis zum Computerquäken.
Und ja, das versuchen wir hier ja auch so ein bisschen abzudecken.
Du deckst ja auch so einiges ab, bist sicherlich auch vielen schon bekannt,
aber ich sage es vielleicht trotzdem mal, du bist so ein Fernsehmensch
und hältst dein Gesicht in die Kamera und versuchst, in zahlreichen Formaten vor allem sehr viel Wissen zu vermitteln,
in zahlreichen Produktionen und bist da sehr umtriebig und machst das auch schon, glaube ich, eine ganze Weile.
Ja, ziemlich lange.
Ich glaube, ich habe 1995 angefangen.
Ja.
Das ist echt krass lang.
Okay. Lass uns doch vielleicht mal genau damit auch einsteigen.
Also vielleicht auch vor 1995.
Ich meine, was hat dich denn so als Kind interessiert?
Yps-Hefte.
Yps-Hefte, okay, mit Gimmikc natürlich.
Na klar.
Ich weiß noch, wie, es gab auch mal diese Yps-Extra-Hefte mit den größeren Gimmicks.
Also ich fand, es gab Gimmicks, die waren langweilig, zum Beispiel mein allererstes weiß ich noch,
das waren Urzeitkrebse.
Klar, Klassiker.
Ja, die haben einfach …
… nicht funktioniert.
Nein.
Ich habe es neulich auch noch mal probiert, es klappt einfach nicht.
Die haben nicht das geliefert, was sie versprochen haben.
Wobei interessanterweise habe ich vor ein paar Jahren mal gelesen,
dass man Urzeitkrebse richtig groß züchten kann, um die dann auch zu essen.
Ernsthaft?
Ja.
Ach so, ich dachte, die sollen irgendwann die Uhrzeit ansagen, das haben sie bei mir nie gemacht.
Ach so, unter dem Aspekt habe ich es nie gesehen.
Also die waren immer langweilig.
Ich fand auch das Playmobil-Männchen bemalen Gimmick total langweilig.
Ich fand die Agenten-Gimmicks fand ich super.
Und ich fand diese größeren Gimmikcs gut.
Ich weiß noch, ich hatte mal so einen schwarzen Zeppelin.
Also im Grunde war es nur eine schwarze Mülltüte eine große, die du mit Luft gefüllt hast
und dann in die Sonne gelegt hast.
Und dann soll es aufsteigen?
Und das war echt super.
Hat funktioniert?
Ja, das hat echt gut funktioniert.
Und solche Sachen, die haben immer Spaß gemacht.
Das ist interessant, dass du das sagst, weil Yps ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen der Versuch,
in diesen ganzen Zeitschriftenmarkt so eine Unterhaltung zu bringen,
die eben nebenbei auch noch Wissen vermittelt.
Ich denke, das war immer so ein bisschen der Selling-Point von Yps
und hat so, glaube ich, frühzeitig auch schon so die Nerds von den anderen,
die halt nur mit Micky Maus und Donald Duck alleine klarkamen, raussortiert so.
Wahrscheinlich ja.
Lustigerweise machen jetzt alle Zeitschriften so Gimmicks vorne drauf
und das meiste ist echt Schrott, also es ist wirklich zum Wegschmeißen nur.
Ja, das ist Tant, Tant ist das Gebilde von Menschenhand, sage ich dann immer.
Und ja, das ist natürlich auch ein Drama, das stimmt.
Aber definitiv Yps hat zumindest mal versucht, eine andere Zielgruppe zu erreichen
und hat das in gewisser Hinsicht auch geschafft.
Also Yps hat mich total beeinflusst und MAD.
Ohja.
Also das waren so die beiden Sachen, die ich mir regelmäßig gekauft habe.
Warum MAD? Also sage mal, warum?
Das ist echt eine gute Frage.
Also es war lustig und es war so ein ganz besonderer Humor.
Ich fand allein schon, dass jede Doppelseite ihre eigene Abteilung hatte,
Abteilung Bergpredigt beispielsweise.
Das stimmt.
Und das war irgendwie, ich habe auch so eine Seelenverwandtschaft zu Alfred Neumann verspürt.
Ich weiß gar nicht so genau warum.
Das ist auch natürlich so ein Außenseiterthema.
Wahrscheinlich ja.
Ja, so das hässliche Kind irgendwie mit der Zahnlücke.
Den abstehenden Ohren.
Ja, so einfach.
Und …
Da hilft dann halt nur noch richtiger Humor irgendwie und der war dann halt auch sehr böse und sehr, wie soll ich sagen, schwarz eigentlich.
Ja.
Gerade zu englisch schon fast, ist ja auch keine deutsche Erfindung in dem Sinne MAD,
Genau.
Aber hat trotzdem, glaube ich, auch in Deutschland ganz gut funktioniert.
Und Alfred Feuerstein das ist ja sozusagen, das fand ich super, als ich dann plötzlich so ein Gesicht zu Alfred Feuerstein hatte.
Ich kannte den Namen wegen der ganzen MAD-Hefte und als er dann irgendwann „Schmidteinander“ gemacht hat,
war mir, ach der ist das.
Er hatte auch was von Alfred E. Neumann irgendwie und er war ja der Chefredakteur über lange Jahre.
Ah okay, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja, das ist so der Mikrokosmos, in dem ich aufgewachsen bin.
Verstehe, MAD und Yps.
Ja.
Okay.
Mehr als drei Buchstaben geht nicht bei mir.
Okay, aber ich meine, was haben sich denn dann für dich daraus für Konsequenzen ergeben?
Ich meine, wohin leitet man dann so sein Interesse?
Also was hat dich gelockt?
Ich meine, es gibt ja so Leute, die sind ja so früh von, keine Ahnung,
hatten wir hier auch schon in zahlreichen Gesprächen so,
ich habe irgendwie die Bienen gesehen und Biologie war mein Feld
und ich wollte nie was anderes machen und so.
Nein, ich wollte eigentlich immer nur Quatsch machen, glaube ich.
Also ich wollte immer nur Sachen ausprobieren.
Und ich hatte auch tatsächlich nach dem Abitur überhaupt keine Ahnung was ich machen sollte.
Ich war total neidisch auf alle meine Freunde, die wussten,
so ich gehe jetzt zum Bund und dann mache ich Berufsakademie
und dann habe ich meine Ausbildung und dann bin ich Ingenieur und das war es dann.
Und da dachte ich, boah ich wünschte, ich wüsste, was ich machen sollte.
Ich hatte null Ahnung, es war für mich so, die Zukunft war ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln.
Alle hatten einen Plan nur ich nicht und das war wirklich, das hat mich echt frustriert.
Ich habe dann erst mal Zivildienst gemacht und habe geguckt,
so ein bisschen Zeit tot zu schlagen, damit ich irgendwie das überbrücken konnte,
aber ich hatte null Ahnung und dann habe ich natürlich immer geguckt,
was kann ich denn so machen?
Wo ergeben sich irgendwelche Möglichkeiten?
Dann habe ich irgendwann angefangen, beim Fernsehen als Praktikant zu arbeiten.
Ich habe bei „Geh auf’s Ganze“ mir Spiele mit ausgedacht.
Das war diese Sendung mit dem Zonk und am Ende den drei Toren,
wo Jörg Dräger den Leuten, die mitspielen, immer so Wahlmöglichkeiten gegeben.
Also entweder nimmst du das, was ich hier in dem Umschlag habe
oder das, was in der Kiste ist.
Und dann haben die sich entschieden für die Kiste, weil die größer ist
und dann hat er gesagt, ich gebe dir aber noch 100 Euro, wenn du das,
oder 100 Mark, wenn du das nimmst, was im Umschlag drin ist.
Und so haben die halt hin und her gedealt.
Und die Niete war der Zonk, das war so eine rote Stoffratte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du dich an die erinnerst.
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht mal sicher, ob ich das jemals gesehen habe.
Lief auf Sat1.
Fernsehen ist nicht so meine Welt.
Das war die Hochzeit der ganzen Gameshows.
Also „Geh auf’s Ganze“ und „Der Preis ist heiß“, das waren so die.
Ja okay, Preis ist heiß das sagt mir was.
Ja und da habe ich angefangen.
Und dann bin ich einfach …
Aber ich meine, wie kommt man denn dazu, also ich meine, oder wie kamst du denn dazu?
Also man marschiert doch dort nicht einfach rein und sagt, ich.
Nein, das ist ein bisschen peinlich, das zu erzählen.
Dann mal los.
Ich habe, sagen wir mal so, ich wusste nicht was ich machen sollte,
aber mir ging es nicht schlecht, weil meine Mutter hat mir immer Taschengeld gegeben.
Und irgendwann meinte sie, so es geht nicht mehr weiter,
du kannst nicht von meinem Geld leben dein ganzes Leben,
du musst jetzt selbst mal was machen.
Und sie hat mir dann ein Praktikum besorgt tatsächlich,
weil sie jemanden kannte, der jemanden kannte.
Und dann bin ich in Köln gelandet bei einer Firma, die hieß Erasmus Film.
Die „Geh auf’s Ganze“ produziert hat.
Verstehe.
Und so kam ich da dran.
Ja und das war ganz nett.
Aber wie war denn dein Verhältnis zu Fernsehen damals?
Ein sehr gutes.
Warum?
Wir hatten kein Babysitter und deshalb hat der Fernseher das übernommen.
Ah okay.
Ja. Also das klingt wie eine ausgedachte Geschichte, aber es ist tatsächlich so,
dass wir oft vor dem Testbild saßen.
/lacht/
Da fing die große Affinität zum Fernsehen an.
Spannender wurde es dann nicht mehr.
Das ist tatsächlich so.
Früher war es ja so, dass immer umgeschaltet worden ist.
Und bei diesen Umschaltaktionen da gab es immer so ein bisschen Leerlauf.
Entweder turnten dann Kätzchen vom HR über irgendsoein komisches Klettergerüst
oder du hattest, auf was ich immer gewartet habe, die Sesamstraße.
Und da kam dann, bevor die Sesamstraße anfing, kam so ein Bild zum Beispiel von Ernie und Bert
und darüber stand, Sesamstraße und darunter Ernie kommt gleich, irgendwie so was.
Ich konnte ja noch nicht lesen, aber ich wusste, okay gleich fängt die Sesamstraße an.
Und das Testbild war für mich einfach nur ein anderes buntes Bild mit Schrift,
da stand ja die Senderkennung und da dachte ich, ja okay,
wenn meine Mutter mir sagt, Ernie kommt gleich würde da stehen,
dann ist das wohl so.
Das hat mich auch null irritiert, dass die ganze Zeit vielleicht nur so ein 1000 Hertz-Ton da lief.
Irgendwann wurde umgeschaltet, da gab es dann WDR2
und meistens zur Mittagszeit Quintessenz, das habe ich dann praktisch über das Testbild gehört, Radio.
Und dann, als dann tatsächlich das echte Bild umgeschaltet wurde, da wusste ich,
okay jetzt gleich geht es wirklich los.
Aber als Kind hast du noch nicht dieses Zeitempfinden, glaube ich, insofern…
Hat man Ausdauer.
Saßen wir stundenlang davor.
Okay, aber dann war es die Sesamstraße, die eigentlich das nächste Bildungsprogramm war?
Genau. Sesamstraße damit bin ich dann groß geworden.
Wer nicht fragt bleibt dumm.
Ja.
Das fand ich eigentlich auch immer ein sehr schönes Thema.
Die gibt es ja auch immer noch.
Denkst du, welche Rolle die Sesamstraße so einnimmt?
Ich glaube, die versuchen das immer noch so ein bisschen zu machen.
Vorschulbildung, also ich habe es ehrlich gesagt auch lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob die noch die einzelnen Buchstaben vorstellen oder bis zehn zählen oder so, ich hoffe.
Das Thema ist immer noch heiß, würde ich sagen.
Ich glaube auch, das sind so die Grundlagen, die muss man einfach drauf haben.
Auf jeden Fall.
Deshalb sage ich auch allen Kindern, die ich treffe, mach auf jeden Fall die Grundschule zu Ende.
/lacht/ Das ist ein guter Rat.
Hast du auch gemacht und dann weiß nicht, dieser Einstieg dann im Fernsehen,
da warst du aber aus der Schule dann…
Da war ich aus der Schule raus.
… auch schon mal raus.
Ja.
Also so Abitur oder so was hast du gemacht?
Ich hatte Abitur, ich habe Zivildienst gemacht und habe so Jobs gemacht
und dann kam irgendwann das Fernsehen.
Und da habe ich dann bei „Geh auf’s Ganze“ gearbeitet und war auf einem Video drauf,
was jemand von Super RTL gesehen hat und der meinte,
den, diesen Ralph, den nehmen wir für diese Tiersendung, die wir vorhaben zu machen.
Weil damals war es so, da fing Super RTL gerade an und die hatten, glaube ich,
noch nicht so viel Werbung verkauft wie sie Platz gehabt hätten
und brauchten so Füllprogramme, so 5-Minuten-Programme.
Und da gab es die verschiedenen Themen und ein Thema war eben so ein Tiermagazin.
Und das habe ich dann gemacht.
Und aus den fünf Minuten wurde dann irgendwann so ein 20-minütiges Programm
und dann ja.
Klingt so nach einer Hape Kerkeling Kein Pardon Story.
Ja, war so ein bisschen, ich habe auch immer alle freundlich gegrüßt.
Hast du auch deine persönliche Glücksmelodie dabei erfahren?
Nein, die hatte ich nicht.
Okay. Aber es lief ja dann doch ganz gut für dich, du hast ja dann relativ schnell dann die Formate gewechselt
und dann kam, glaube ich, irgendwann auch die Maus.
Genau.
Die ja so ein bisschen auch wieder so ein Klassiker der Wissensvermittlung ist, finde ich, in Deutschland.
Absolut.
Also das war ja oder ist auch immer noch, finde ich, der ikonischste Freund der Kinder,
wenn man jetzt aus dem Samson und Tiffy Alter raus ist,
wobei die Maus irgendwie auch nicht nur zeitlos ist, sondern auch irgendwie generationsbefreit.
Also ich kenne eigentlich niemanden, der der Maus überdrüssig geworden ist.
Also vielleicht in der Pubertät kurz, dass du denkst, ey das ist Kinderprogramm.
Aber das kommt dann auf jeden Fall wieder, weil ja der Erzählstil an sich auch schon extrem,
wie soll ich sagen, so ein Klassiker geworden ist.
Ich meine, man kennt ja das so, jeder hat irgendwann mal so eine Mausparodie gemacht.
Also so in der Art, irgendein Thema auf Maus-Art erklärt und jeder weiß sofort, wie das gemeint ist.
Das ist ja schon eine Leistung, die man an der Stelle anerkennen muss, dass das gut funktioniert.
Ja und die Geschichte wie das kam dieser Mausduktus, das erzählt Armin immer total gerne.
Wenn es dich interessiert, kann ich kurz die Kurzfassung.
Kannst auch gerne die längere Fassung machen, wir haben ja Zeit.
Also als die angefangen haben, die ersten Sachgeschichten zu machen, da gab es nur Musik.
Es gab keinen Kommentar.
Und irgendwann gab es dann Beschwerden von dem Publikum, die sagen, ihr macht ja die Kinder sprachlos,
da muss doch auch was gesagt werden und immer nur die Musik, das ist doch nicht in Ordnung.
Und dann hat Armin irgendwann angefangen, einen Film zu machen, und wie das dann so ist,
du schneidest den Film fertig und gehst dann damit zu dem Redakteur,
spielst den Film vor und sprichst praktisch so ins Blaue hinein, was du eigentlich als Kommentartext sagen wirst,
wenn der Text fertig geschrieben ist.
Und Armin hat das gemacht und der WDR-Redakteur meinte, ja prima, mach das genau so.
Und dann hat Armin den Text geschrieben, hat den ganz klassisch aufgenommen, Sprachaufnahme gemacht,
hat das alles zusammengemischt und wieder vorgestellt und der Redakteur fand es überhaupt nicht gut.
Der meinte, nein so wollte ich das nicht, das klingt ja total langweilig, das ist ja so wie alle anderen.
Ich wollte es so, wie du es mir …
… gerade eben erzählt hast.
… vorgesprochen hast.
Ja und so fing das an, dass Armin tatsächlich keine Texte mehr in dem klassischen Sinn geschrieben hat,
sondern den Beitrag, die Sachgeschichte live vertont hat mehr oder weniger.
Hat auch immer das erzählt, was er gerade sieht, hat keine Metaebene aufgemacht,
sondern blieb immer am Bild und es war immer sehr dicht dadurch
und dadurch so entstand das alles und das war eine gute Schule
jetzt für mich auch zu lernen, was das besondere ist, nämlich dass es ganz anders ist
als zum Beispiel bei so Tierdokumentationen, wo du siehst, wie der Löwe das Zebra reißt,
aber der Sprecher macht irgendwie so einen Ausflug in keine Ahnung was noch alles da erzählt wird über das Habitat der Löwen,
was man gar nicht sieht.
Und bei der Maus ist es immer so, dass wir immer am Bild bleiben
und immer nur das erzählen, was gerade sichtbar ist.
Das ist so ein bisschen der Unterschied zwischen einer Radioreportage über ein Fußballspiel und wie es im Fernsehen ist,
wo man dann immer so viele nebensächliche Informationen dargereicht bekommt,
weil die Leute immer denken, das Bild alleine würde schon in irgendeiner Form ausreichen.
Dabei ist eigentlich das unmittelbare im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, also ohne ein weiteres Medium,
das man dann einfach das noch mal aktiv beschrieben bekommt, was passiert,
weil es meiner Auffassung nach dadurch noch etwas wirklicher und direkter und fassbarer wird.
Absolut, also ich finde auch Radioreportagen über Fußball, und das sage ich als nicht-Fußballfan,
kann ich mir total gut anhören, ich finde das ist richtig spannend, das ist wirklich toll und eine unglaubliche Leistung.
So reden zu können, ist wirklich großartig.
Geheimtipp ist immer, Fernsehbild einschalten, aber Ton aus und dazu die Radioreportage.
Ja, das Schlimme ist nur, dass es dann oft nicht synchron ist.
Ja, das ist aber nur ein technisches Problem, das kann man irgendwie lösen.
Mit Armin meinst du natürlich Armin Maiwald, der das alles quasi losgetreten hat und immer noch macht.
Er macht es immer noch, ja.
Obwohl er schon über 80 ist.
Armin ist über 80, die Maus ist über 50.
Also wir haben ja 2021 50 Jahre Maus gefeiert, Wahnsinn.
Das ist in der Tat irre.
Und was, ich meine, jetzt sind wir bei einem interessanten Punkt, Lach- und Sachgeschichten.
Ich weiß nicht, seit wann es den Begriff gibt, aber es zeigt ja auch …
Seit Anfang an.
… es geht halt nicht nur um das Wissen, sondern es geht auch immer ein bisschen um den Humor.
Ja, wobei genau.
Also es gibt aber auch gleichzeitig so diese Trennung oder gab es jahrelang.
Du hast einmal die Sachgeschichten, wo Sachen erklärt werden und die Lachgeschichten, wo du Zeit zum Lachen hast.
Die wurden nicht miteinander verknüpft.
Zwar waren die auch mal unterhaltsam oder eigentlich immer unterhaltsam die Sachgeschichten,
aber es gab schon eine ganz klare Trennung,
also hier lernt man was und auf der anderen Seite kannst du entspannen und einfach nur mitsingen.
Die Maus halt und der Elefant.
Zum Beispiel ja.
Und das hat sich so ein bisschen gewandelt.
Also es gibt inzwischen auch Sachgeschichten, die total unterhaltsam sind.
Auf eine Art unterhaltsam, die es vor 40 Jahren vielleicht so nicht gegeben hätte.
Und das finde ich ganz gut, weil das ist ja auch bei „Wissen macht Ah“ der Fall.
Ich finde, dass Fernsehen in erster Linie ein Unterhaltungsmedium ist.
Es muss einfach Spaß machen, das zu gucken.
Wenn es keinen Spaß macht, wenn es langweilig ist, dann schaltet es keiner ein
und dann, wenn es keiner einschaltet, dann kannst du die tollsten Sachen erklären,
wenn es keiner mitbekommt, ist es irgendwie sinnlos.
Und das ist so ein bisschen der Angang gewesen bei „Wissen macht Ah“ eigentlich,
dass wir versucht haben, das immer unterhaltsam zu machen
So ein bisschen wie bei dem Hund von meinen Eltern.
Das war ein Bobtail und dieser Bobtail hatte immer ordentliche Verdauungsprobleme
und hat Durchfall gehabt und weil da viel Fell am Hintern ist, verklebte das Fell am Hintern
und das war wie so ein Pfropfen.
Das heißt, der Durchfall fiel weiter durch, kam aber nicht raus, der Druck wurde immer größer
und irgendwann platzte das auf und das war echt unschön, vor allem wenn man das Sonntagmorgens beim Frühstück erlebte.
Und irgendwann hat dann, ich weiß nicht, meine Mutter die Idee gehabt, die auf der Hand liegt,
die Medizin für den Hund ihm nicht einfach so zu geben, weil das spuckte er immer wieder aus,
sondern schön in Leberwurst eingepackt.
Wenn also die Pille in Leberwurst drin ist, dann frisst der Hund einfach nur, freut sich, denkt sich,
oh geil Leberwurst und merkt gar nicht, wie er diese Pille mit runterschluckt und wird gesund.
Und so ähnlich ist es eigentlich auch beim Fernsehen.
Das heißt, die Unterhaltung ist die Leberwurst und die Fakten, die man vielleicht vermittelt
oder das Wissen, was man vermittelt, ist im Grunde diese Pille.
Aber das würde ja dann implizieren, dass das eigentliche Wissen eine bittere Pille ist.
Nein, das heißt eigentlich, dass die meisten Leute, wenn sie Wissen hören und Lernen hören sofort in ihrer Schulzeit sind.
Und da gibt es nicht so die schönen, wahrscheinlich für viele Leute nicht die tollsten Erinnerungen an die Schulzeit und an das Lernen.
Wie sind denn deine Erinnerungen an die Schulzeit?
Ich fand es relativ langweilig.
Ich fand es schön, meine Freunde da zu treffen.
Ja okay, aber warum war es langweilig, weil es nicht unterhaltsam war oder weil es keine Leberwurst gab?
Also es war nicht unterhaltsam, es gab auch unterhaltsame Lehrer auf jeden Fall,
aber die meisten haben ihren Stoff einfach durchgezogen und für das meiste hatte ich noch nicht die nötige geistige Reife,
um das gut zu finden oder um das zu verstehen.
Und bei vielen Sachen hat sich es mir einfach auch nicht erklärt, wofür brauche ich das jetzt eigentlich?
Es war überhaupt nicht in meiner, es hatte überhaupt nichts mit meiner Lebenswelt zu tun.
Und das fand ich, glaube ich, etwas, was die meisten Lehrerinnen und Lehrer nicht geschafft haben,
mir klar zu machen, warum es cool ist, das zu wissen.
Wenn das natürlich so ein bisschen, immer sehr schade, man hört das ja oft, ich meine,
ich kenne das natürlich auch genauso aus der Schule, man erinnert sich eigentlich immer an die Lehrer,
die besonders lustig waren oder mir geht es zumindest so, dass da, wo das Entertainment auch irgendwie eine wichtige Rolle gespielt hat,
sich die Bereitschaft, die Inhalte wahrzunehmen und aber auch vor allem die Inhalte selber deutlich besser eingeprägt haben.
Absolut.
Weil man Bilder geliefert bekommen hat.
Ich werde nie vergessen, wie mein Englischlehrer uns das Wort Suspicious erklären wollte.
Was ist denn so Suspicious, natürlich hätte er es einfach übersetzen können,
aber der Unterricht war immer auch komplett auf Englisch.
Und er hat dann einfach so pantomimisch sich irgendwie hingestellt und gesagt,
ja hier ist jetzt so eine Ladenfront, hier ist eine große Glasscheibe und stand so entspannt so daneben
und warf so einen virtuellen Backstein irgendwie so in seiner Hand hoch.
Das ist halt sowohl lustig als auch einprägsam, also klar, das ist mal echt verdächtigt.
Und diese Dinge, glaube ich, sind in der Schule halt selten.
Man kann jetzt natürlich auch nicht unbedingt jetzt von jeder Lehrerin, jedem Lehrer erwarten,
auch diese clowneske Fähigkeit zu haben, aber ich denke, auch oft ist es auch …
Muss auch nicht.
Ja, es wird aber auch vor allem, glaube ich, so ein bisschen als unerwünscht angesehen.
Ja, aber manchmal hast du auch Lehrer, die denken, okay das muss hier alles lustig sein
und dann spielen die so was lustiges, aber das ist dann eher so …
Fremdschämmäßig.
Ja absolut.
Ja, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Und junge Menschen haben ein sehr feines Gespür dafür, ob was echt ist oder nicht echt ist, glaube ich.
Und wenn da was nicht echt ist, sondern nur so vorgegaukelt, dann sind die wie die Löwen,
die so auf ein lahmes Zebra stürzen.
Aber ist halt trotzdem schade, dass wie du das auch gerade gesagt hast,
dass Schule dann auch automatisch eben einem Wissensvermittlung oder -erlangung schon abgewöhnt,
weil es ja eigentlich das ist, was ja Kinder wollen.
Absolut. Und ich glaube, es liegt auch zu einem großen Teil daran, dass Schule einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß ist
in der Art und Weise wie die organisiert ist.
Weil es ist ja, eigentlich ist Schule ja so ein Überbleibsel der Industrialisierung.
Das heißt, man hat versucht, so die Workforce heranzubilden, dass Leute eben vielleicht auch schriftliche Arbeitsanweisungen lesen und umsetzen können.
Dass du einfach so ein Rädchen bist im großen Getriebe, um es mal ganz platt zu sagen.
Ja.
Aber diese Anforderung an uns Menschen gibt es ja jetzt in dem Sinne nicht mehr.
Wir müssen ja viel kreativer werde, um Probleme zu lösen.
Es ist nicht mehr so, dass wir einfach nur Anweisungen bekommen und die umsetzen müssen.
Und es ist auch nicht mehr so, also ich glaube zum Beispiel Noten, damit tun wir uns inzwischen keinen Gefallen mehr,
dass wir alles benoten müssen, dass wir jeden Menschen benoten müssen.
Gucken, ob der den Lernstand so beherrscht wie es sein sollte.
Weil es ist nun mal so, manche Menschen finden Mathe total super und andere denken sich lieber Geschichten aus.
Und natürlich muss man so eine Basis haben, das ist überhaupt keine Frage,
aber diese individuelle Förderung der einzelnen Fähigkeiten und Talente, das kommt in der Schule viel zu kurz.
Auch es kommt viel zu kurz so eine Fehlerkultur heranzubilden.
Es kommt zu kurz, dass man sagt, ja mach einen Fehler, wir sind nur so geworden wie wir geworden sind durch Versuch und Irrtum
und nicht durch Versuch und alles richtig machen.
Aber wenn du dich irrst in der Schule, wenn du was falsch machst, dann kriegst du eine schlechte Note.
Was lerne ich daraus?
Ich halte lieber mal den Ball flach, wenn ich was nicht weiß, bevor ich irgendwas riskiere.
Und das bringt uns aber nicht weiter.
Das stimmt.
Und ist auch die Annahme, dass jeder eben zu einem gleichen Zeitpunkt ein bestimmtes Wissen /unverständlich/.
Kann ja sein, dass man einfach auch in seiner persönlichen Entwicklung erst mal so zwei Jahre andere Sachen wichtiger findet.
Absolut.
Und das später machen kann.
Aber ich denke, die Flexibilisierung im Bildungsbereich, da gibt es auch noch viel drüber zu reden.
Aber lass uns noch mal auf das Fernsehen kommen und konkret dann auch mal auf „Wissen macht Ah“.
Wie ist denn dieses Format überhaupt entstanden?
Wer hat sich denn das ausgedacht?
Woraus, gab es da ein Vorbild oder ist das so aus dem Nichts?
Das ist eigentlich aus dem Nichts entstanden.
Also es war ja so, als ich mit der Sendung bei Super RTL aufgehört habe,
war ich eigentlich ganz froh, weil ich nämlich gleichzeitig angefangen habe zu studieren.
Und irgendwann bin ich aus der Straßenbahn ausgestiegen, um zur Hochschule zu gehen
und bin da von einer jungen Frau angesprochen worden und die fragte mich,
ob ich der sei, der bei Super RTL dieses Tiermagazin macht und ob ich nicht mal mich bei dieser Nummer melden könnte,
weil die vom WDR neue Moderatoren suchen für eine Sendung.
Und die wollten mich anrufen, hatten meine Nummer nicht, aber jetzt wo sie mich hier trifft, ich soll mich da mal melden.
Das habe ich gemacht und dann habe ich da eine Probesendung gemacht für den Maus-Club,
das war so ein Spin-Off von der Sendung mit der Maus, wo auch im Grunde kleine Sachgeschichten gezeigt worden sind,
aber es gab eben auch Publikum im Studio.
Und da war auch die Frau, die mich angesprochen hat, das war Shary.
Das heißt, wir haben dann zusammen angefangen, das …
Shary Reeves.
Genau. Und der Maus-Club lief dann ein paar Jahre, den gab es auch vorher schon.
Und dann irgendwann war das auch vorbei mit dem Maus-Club und wurde nicht weiter produziert.
Aber der WDR hatte halt diese ganzen kleinen Sachgeschichten, die da im Maus-Club liefen,
die waren irgendwie noch im Archiv und die waren erst einmal gezeigt worden.
Und da war die Idee, können wir nicht eine Sendung machen jetzt jenseits von diesem Clubding mit Publikum,
sondern was kleines, feines, wo wir einfach noch mal diese ganzen Beiträge zeigen können.
Und dann haben wir überlegt, okay, wie könnte denn eine Sendung aussehen, die wir gerne gucken würden?
Der Maus-Club war sehr bunt und hell und irgendwie hatten wir so ein Gefühl,
eigentlich wäre es ganz schön, wenn wir erst mal so ein ganz dunkles Studio haben,
also schwarz als Grundfarbe und dann ja füllen wir das langsam mit Leben.
Also wir heißt, du und Shary, ihr habt euch das ausgedacht oder wer war da noch alles?
Genau, Shary, ich, die Redaktion, das waren so die handvoll.
Wie groß ist so eine Redaktion?
Das waren zwei, Ulrike Müller-Haupt und Joachim Lachmuth.
Das heißt, man setzt sich jetzt wirklich mal so konkret zusammen und sagt, ich will jetzt mal was neues bauen.
Wie kann das aussehen, ja.
Und dann haben wir das, dann wurde da tatsächlich auch ein Set gebaut.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Reste waren, aber der Inhalt der Sendung, also die Beiträge,
waren im Grunde, das war wie so eine Wiederhol-, Abspielstation.
Und eigentlich war das nur geplant für ein paar Folgen, bis dann alle Sendungen, alle Filme noch mal gezeigt worden sind,
die irgendwie gut waren.
Wer hat sich den Namen ausgedacht?
Der ist von mir.
Wie bist du darauf gekommen?
Eigentlich sollte die Sendung nur „Ah!“ heißen.
Und es war auch alles so geplant und wir hatten ein großes Holz A mit so einem ausziehbaren Ausrufezeichen.
Und als wir das erste Mal im Studio waren kam der Redakteur und meinte,
ja wir müssen uns leider mal kurz unterhalten, weil also die in der Hierarchieebene oben drüber die meinen,
Ah ist einfach zu kurz, die wollen jetzt die Sendung „Schlau TV“ nennen.
Oh Gott.
Und ich so, nein.
/lacht/
Nein, Schlau TV bei aller Liebe, nein.
Ja.
Und wir hatten ja dieses Ah und dann war mir klar, okay, der Titel muss länger sein.
Und wir haben das Ah also, dann saßen wir da im Büro und haben Sachen überlegt
und irgendwann dachte ich, ich habe ja vorher „Muh, das Tiermagazin“ gemacht,
die Kuh macht muh und Wissen macht ah, das lag irgendwie auf der Hand.
Außerdem ist ja Wissen ist Macht, sagt man, und dann hast du Wissen, macht und Ah und das passte irgendwie.
Und das ging dann auch durch.
Das war ein total bescheuerter Titel, alle fanden, was soll denn das, was heißt denn das, verstehen wir nicht.
Aber ich bin irgendwie hartnäckig geblieben und seitdem heißt das so.
Glücklicherweise, ich finde den Titel wirklich hervorragend.
Weil er halt wirklich so diesen Heureka-Moment in gewisser Hinsicht noch mal anders einpackt so
und dieses, ah jetzt habe ich es auch verstanden so.
Und es ist, wenn dann der Groschen fällt und die Leute, ach so ist das gemeint, dann ist es genau…
Dann ist das genau der Effekt.
Es ist im Grunde ein rekursiver Titel.
Das stimmt. /lacht/ Fantastisch, okay.
Das heißt, …
Eigentlich war es nur eine Abspielstation.
Ach so ja …
Es war nur so ein Provisorium.
Und dann irgendwie lief das aber überraschenderweise total erfolgreich.
Leute haben das geguckt und fanden das lustig.
War denn der Moderationsstil von Anfang an so wie er dann auch immer weiter war?
Naja, nicht ganz.
Also die Produktionsfirma, die vorher den Maus-Club produziert hat, die haben eigentlich ja,
die haben die ersten paar Sendungen auch vorbereitet.
Aber das war nicht so vorbereitet, dass wir das Gefühl hatten, wir sind jetzt hier irgendwie,
das war alles sehr improvisiert.
Und nach ein paar Sendungen habe ich dann gesagt, so geht es nicht, weil das kommt von der Zeit nicht hin
und das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen einfach nur heiße Luft, was wir sagen.
Da fehlt mir Inhalt.
Und dann habe ich angefangen zu schreiben, habe einfach dann die Texte geschrieben.
Ich glaube, nach der fünften Sendung.
Und habe das bis heute mache ich das so, dass ich eben mir genau überlege,
okay was sind die Beiträge und was kann man zwischendurch machen,
um die Beiträge vielleicht noch ein bisschen gehaltvoller zu machen oder vielleicht fehlt irgendwie eine Information
oder müsste man noch irgendwie ein bisschen genauer drauf eingehen.
Oder vielleicht gibt es Versuche, die man nebenher machen kann, um den Beiträgen noch mehr mitzugeben.
Und so kam das, dass ich angefangen habe, mir das eben alles aufzuschreiben haarklein.
Dass wir auch wussten, okay wir haben so und so viel Zeit und mit dem Text, den wir machen,
kommen wir gut über die Sendung und müssen nicht irgendwie am Ende noch fünf Minuten füllen
und wissen nicht, was wir sagen sollen.
Das war es, wie es dann dazu kam.
Und dann irgendwann hatte die Redakteurin vom KiKa das Angebot, dass „Wissen macht Ah!“ Täglich ausgestrahlt werden könnte.
Das war eigentlich nur eine Sendung für den Samstagmorgen.
Und ich fand das ehrlich gesagt total, das war wie so, also das hat sich mir überhaupt nicht erschlossen,
warum man eine Sendung, die für wöchentlich konzipiert ist, plötzlich täglich ausstrahlen sollte.
Weil das bedeutete ja, erstens haben wir nicht genügend Sendungen, es muss total viel wiederholt werden
und zweitens werden wir uns wahrscheinlich tot senden und Leute finden das langweilig,
weil sie nur noch „Wissen macht Ah!“ jeden Abend sehen.
Aber sie war da hartnäckig und meinte, doch das ist genau richtig und da hatte sie auch echt recht.
Weil durch dieses von montags bis donnerstags immer um 19:25 Uhr kam „Wissen macht Ah!“.
Das hat der Bekanntheit, es war wie so ein Raketenantrieb, das war unglaublich.
Ja, ist ja so ein Tagesschau-Effekt.
Ich meine, alles was täglich kommt, hat auf einmal eine ganz andere Bedeutung.
Und ich hatte auch immer so den Eindruck, dass man eigentlich auch ja salopp gesagt,
eigentlich auch gar nicht genug davon bekommen konnte, also es war irgendwie so ein …
ich habe das immer sehr geschätzt, dass die Moderation sehr humorvoll war, locker war,
auch nicht so einen Stock im Arsch hatte, wie du das schon andeutest, dass man dann halt auch mal mit so ein paar Nicklichkeiten daherkommen kann
und es einfach immer so ein bisschen den Bogen überspannt und nicht so angepasst eben langweilig rüberkommt.
So ich meine, das ist ja ganz offensichtlich so ein bisschen auch das Salz in der Suppe gewesen,
abgesehen davon, dass halt auch die Auswahl der Themen, was halt jetzt wirklich erklärt wurde,
auch noch mal so ein bisschen so Sesamstraße plus war.
Also es war einfach mehr Sachen, die einen halt wirklich auch täglich im Leben mit Redewendungen und so weiter,
also man hatte diesen Ah-Effekt eigentlich immer auch schon bei der Frage.
So dieses, ja klar.
Das sind so Sachen, die du gar nicht wusstest, dass du dir da die Frage stellst.
Also zum Beispiel hatten wir jetzt gerade im Studio die Frage,
warum haben eigentlich Windräder, also diese Windturbinen, drei Blätter, drei Rotorblätter und nicht vier oder ganz viele?
Das ist ja was, das siehst du jeden Tag eigentlich und die Frage stellt sich den wenigsten Menschen, denke ich,
dabei ist es so offensichtlich.
Außer Eltern natürlich, das ist halt so die klassische Situation, wenn einen Kinder halt fragen, warum ist irgendwie X sowieso?
Und dann denkt man ja immer so, ja noch nie drüber nachgedacht so.
Genau.
Heutzutage hat man Gott sei Dank Wikipedia und kann irgendwie sich das dann mal auch aufhelfen.
Aber in solchen Momenten hat man ja früher eigentlich immer erst gemerkt, was man eigentlich alles nicht weiß.
Absolut.
Genau.
Und das ist im Grunde auch so eine immerwährende Fortbildungsmaßnahme gewesen.
Alles was ich eigentlich gemacht habe beim Fernsehen, weil ich im Grunde ja von nichts Ahnung habe.
Ich meine, was natürlich auch eine Rolle gespielt hat, ist so die Dynamik zwischen dir und Shary,
die ja auch so ein totaler Tausendsassa ist, deren Vita lässt mich immer wieder das Hirn rauchen.
Irgendwie also von Profifußballerin zu Hiphop-Sängerin irgendwie alles dabei
und mit allem auch irgendwie erklecklich erfolgreich, das ist schon bemerkenswert.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und dieses Spiel, was ihr da auch immer gespielt habt, also immer so ein latenter Diss,
der irgendwie so drin ist, aber eigentlich auch immer so eine Freundschaft auch wieder gezeigt hat.
So, dass man irgendwie auch mal so ein bisschen spitz miteinander sein kann, ohne dass es gleich irgendwie einen Keil zwischen einen treibt.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch ein sehr schönes Element gewesen.
Das stimmt, ja es war immer so eine…
wir kennen uns halt ewig lange schon und das ist lustigerweise auch immer die erste Frage gewesen von Kindern,
die uns auf der Straße getroffen haben, immer so, seid ihr eigentlich befreundet?
Wie meinst du das mit befreundet?
Ja, so wie meine Eltern.
Nein, so befreundet sind wir nicht, wir kennen uns, aber wir sind jetzt kein Paar in der Art.
Und ja das kam halt immer so rüber und wir verstehen uns einfach auch gut.
Und es war immer nett, auch wenn wir uns gekebbelt haben oder Shary so ein bisschen überrascht war
oder genervt vielleicht auch und das war nicht unbedingt immer nur gespielt,
das war tatsächlich auch manchmal, ich glaube, ich habe den Bogen das eine oder andere Mal ein bisschen überspannt.
Ja gut, aber es bleibt dann halt auch drin im Format so.
Ich denke, das war dann auch ein wenig der Wegbereiter.
Weil ich glaube, immer in dem Moment, wo man dann eben auch meint, sich an eine Öffentlichkeit in irgendeiner Form im Verhalten anpassen zu müssen,
also quasi deren Erwartungshaltung versucht einzupreisen, in dem Moment verliert man dann auch schnell die Authentizität
und damit auch so ein bisschen sein eigenes Mojo, weil es ja dann auch immer Spaß macht,
den Bogen immer ein bisschen zu überspannen, um dann eben auch vielleicht im richtigen Moment wieder den Schritt zurückzugehen und zu sagen, ja…
Ja und dieses Gefühl dafür zu haben, was ich selbst eigentlich gut finde, das ist etwas, was total wichtig ist.
Das trifft für alle Menschen zu, glaube ich, für Lehrerinnen und Lehrer, die denken,
ich möchte eigentlich gar nicht hier Entertainment machen, ich möchte hier meine Formeln ganz normal aufschreiben.
Und das kommt dann authentisch rüber und auch lustig.
Also ein Mathelehrer von mir, der mal, ich glaube, irgendeine lange Formel aufgeschrieben hat
und hat so doof an der Tafel angefangen, dass die Tafel nicht ausreichte, hat dann einfach an der Wand weitergeschrieben
und so was bleibt natürlich irgendwie hängen, weil das lustig ist, weil er plötzlich so ein Regelbrecher ist,
obwohl er Mathelehrer war.
Und dieses Gefühl dafür zu haben, was ich selbst mag und was ich selbst gut finde, sich daran zu halten ist total wichtig.
Das war ja, eigentlich wollte ich ja Design studieren und wenn man so was studieren will,
dann musst du halt eine Mappe abgeben.
Und ich habe bei dem ersten Mal mir überlegt, okay, was könnte denn wohl diese Prüfungskommission sehen wollen
und habe versucht, deren Geschmack zu treffen und damit bin ich halt komplett gescheitert,
weil das natürlich Schwachsinn ist, den Geschmack von irgendjemandem zu treffen, den du gar nicht kennst.
Und das war insgesamt eine sehr frustrierende Erfahrung und ich habe mir geschworen,
nie wieder so einen Scheiß wie eine Mappe zu machen, weil das war einfach nicht für mich.
Und dann irgendwann, als ich bei „Geh auf’s Ganze“ arbeitete, war eine Kollegin,
die sich an der Kunsthochschule für Medien in Köln beworben hat und die hat mir mal gezeigt,
was sie so alles macht für die Mappe und ich dachet, ach das ist aber nett, das klingt wie nach einer guten Schule, das könnte mir gefallen.
Und habe dann doch noch so eine Mappe gemacht für die Schule.
Habe aber eigentlich nur Sachen reingetan, die ich so für mich in den vergangenen Monaten so gemacht habe
und habe das einfach nur zusammengestellt und habe die Mappe abgegeben und dachte,
wenn die mich annehmen, super, dann bin hundertprozentig ich angenommen worden, weil ich mich nicht verstellt habe.
Und wenn die mich nicht annehmen, dann passt es auch nicht.
Hast du da auch nichts zu suchen, ja.
Und dann kam diese, ich weiß, dass die auch so eine Woche hatten mit Gesprächen mit der Prüfungskommission,
wo dann sozusagen die Leute, die sich bewerben, dann noch mal auf Herz und Nieren geprüft werden im persönlichen Gespräch.
Die Woche kam und ging und ich hatte keine Einladung bekommen und ich dachte,
okay, das ist ein bisschen schade, aber ist auch okay, also war jetzt nicht so super frustrierend wie die ersten Mappen, die ich abgegeben habe.
Weil ich eine ganz andere Haltung hatte.
Und dann kam irgendwann wieder ein paar Wochen später dann der Brief von der Kunsthochschule,
und das hat mich ein bisschen gewundert, weil der nicht per Einschreiben kam wie alle anderen Absageschreiben.
Und ich habe den so aufgemacht und wie man das so macht, man zieht so den Brief so ein bisschen aus dem Umschlag
und liest erst mal, okay, da steht jetzt „Lieber Ralph Caspers“, da steht nicht „sehr geehrter Ralph Caspers“,
war überhaupt nicht förmlich und das Gefühl war, also die Absagen von denen sind aber sehr sehr locker gehalten.
Und dann habe ich den komplett aufgemacht den Brief und habe gesehen, dass ich angenommen worden bin.
Und es war wie so ein Schlüsselerlebnis, dass ich plötzlich merkte, ah, also wenn ich Sachen so mache,
dass sie mir gefallen, dann ist es viel besser, als wenn ich versuche, den Geschmack von jemand anderem zu treffen.
Weil selbst wenn ich der einzige Mensch bin, dem das gefällt wie ich es gemacht habe,
gibt es wenigstens einen Menschen, dem es gefällt.
Wenn ich aber was mache, was nicht mal mir gefällt und was auch nicht so einer Prüfungskommission gefällt,
dann bin ich im Grunde doppelt gearscht, weil ich habe damit überhaupt nichts erreicht.
Und das fand ich irgendwie …
Ja im schlimmsten Fall wird man auch noch für einen Job rekrutiert, wo man dann Dinge tun muss,
die einem ja eigentlich gar nicht gefallen, das ist noch schlimmer.
Ja, kommt noch dazu.
Und das fand ich wirklich, das war wie so eine Offenbarung.
Und das haben wir eben oder ich versuche es bei allen Sendungen so zu machen,
dass ich mir das gerne angucke.
Also im Grunde ist „Wissen macht Ah!“ kein Kinderfernsehen, sondern Ralph-Fernsehen.
Und Quarks, wenn ich das mache, ist auch zu großen Teilen Ralph-Fernsehen,
weil ich das so mache, wie ich es gut finde und wie es mir gefallen würde.
Weil das Ding ist ja auch, wenn ich was mache und ich habe keinen Spaß daran,
dann kann ich nicht erwarten, dass andere Leute Spaß daran haben.
Ja. Das merkt man auch gleich in Sachen.
Dann ist es einfach halt auch gar nicht mehr humorvoll und dann passt es nicht.
Ja dann kannst du es direkt sein lassen eigentlich.
Ja. Ihr habt da bei „Wissen macht Ah!“ noch so einen anderen Begriff zum Glühen gebracht, nämlich klugscheißen.
Was ja so eine generelle negative Konnotation hat und wahrscheinlich an der Stelle auch bewusst verwendet wurde.
Absolut ja.
Weil so Klugscheißer sind ja eigentlich…
… die, die nicht in die Clubs reinkommen.
Genau, die nicht in die Clubs reinkommen, aber die halt auch immer so latent nerven.
Und ich meine, jeder wird das von sich wahrscheinlich auch schon mal gekannt haben,
also ich kenne das zumindest von mir, dass man natürlich schon irgendwann mal an so einen Punkt kommt,
wo man sich denkt, was ich alles weiß und so, so eine gewisse, wie soll ich sagen,
Minderwertigkeit bei anderen vermeint auszumachen und die einen dann in irgendeiner Form in so eine Position hebt,
man müsste jetzt mal alle Dinge irgendwie richtig stellen, weil man hat ja irgendwie das alles mit Löffeln gefressen und so.
Und natürlich ist es klar und auch in gewisser Hinsicht richtig so, dass dann halt solche Klugscheißer dann auch so ihre Grenzen aufgezeigt bekommen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Trotzdem ist es ja hier bewusst dann eben auch in so einer positiven Umkehrung, so nach dem Motto,
ja klugscheißen ist auch was gutes, also Wissen ist toll.
Und es ist ja auch so ein bisschen so wie dieser Begriff Nerd, der eigentlich auch so als Diminutiv gedacht war,
um so Leute herabzusetzen, so ja ihr so mit eurem Wissen und so weiter, Wissen ist dann halt einfach nicht sexy.
Sexy ist halt…
Die Muskeln.
Ja, kiffen, Sport machen, was weiß ich, was halt so Jugendliche auch so normalerweise so toll finden
und wenn da halt so Leute mit ihrem Wissen ankommen und dann auf einmal nur so mit ihrem Kopf,
wo man irgendwie überhaupt nicht aussehen muss und irgendwie überhaupt nichts geleistet haben muss,
das hat so in der Gesellschaft oft erst mal so einen niedrigen Stellungswert.
Also hier und da mag es anders sein, aber so generell findet man das immer wieder so,
dass halt so die Brillenschlangen dann, irgendwie die immer alles besser wissen wollen,
ja komm mir nicht so, weil da kann ich dir jetzt irgendwie eh nichts bringen
und dann wird man halt auch schnell ausgegrenzt, das heißt, man kriegt dann eben auch schnell so einen Backlash,
so nach dem Motto, Wissen ist nicht cool, Wissen ist nicht sexy, Wissen ist irgendwie doof.
Gibt es natürlich auch so Gegenbewegungen bis hin zur Sapiosexualität,
wo sich Leute genau davon angezogen fühlen.
Aber was hat euch da jetzt sozusagen dazu gebracht, das so Front and Centre mit als Tagline einzubringen?
Ehrlich gesagt, Provokation war das glaube ich.
Weil scheiße sagt man ja nicht.
Stimmt.
Und das war aber gleichzeitig so klugscheißen, also es hatte eigentlich was wissendes,
das war so einer der Gründe.
Lustige Geschichte übrigens, alle dritten Programme haben „Wissen macht Ah!“ ja gezeigt
und die Tagline „Klugscheißen mit Shary und Ralph“ wurde auch überall übernommen, außer in einem Sender.
Lass mich raten.
Rate.
Bayrischer Rundfunk.
Ja genau.
/lacht/ Ich habe es nicht gewusst.
Da hieß es dann, „Wissen macht Ah! Besserwissen mit Shary und Ralph“, fand ich super.
Ist inzwischen auch wieder anders, aber es war genau das eigentlich, in diese Richtung sollte es gehen.
Es sollte so ein bisschen irritieren.
Ich finde, Irritationen und das habe ich aus dem MAD-Heft eigentlich, finde ich großartig.
So ein bisschen, ich mag es, wenn Sachen so am Chaos entlangschrabben und wenn man nicht genau weiß,
okay, wie wird es sich jetzt entwickeln, und das ist einfach bei „Wissen macht Ah!“ oft so gewesen.
Und da habe ich total Spaß dabei und klugscheißen war eben ganz genau das.
Wir haben uns das zueigen gemacht, dass wir zu jedem Scheiß was kluges sagen können im Grunde.
Und dass es eben auch Spaß machen kann.
Also das habe ich gemerkt, als ich bei „Geh auf’s Ganze“ gearbeitet habe.
Ich war der einzige Mann in einer Redaktion von vier Frauen und ich war aber so was,
ich war nicht als Mann da, ich war eigentlich als Neutrum da.
Es war so ein bisschen wie, so habe ich es mir immer in der Mädchenumkleidekabine vorgestellt.
Die Themen, über die die gesprochen haben, das war für mich so, wah, ich wusste gar nicht,
dass man über so was reden kann.
Aber seitdem stand ich auf keiner Party mehr allein, weil ich immer was zu so …
… dazu sagen konntest.
… zu so speziellen Themen was sagen konnte.
Und da fand ich zum ersten Mal, dass klugscheißen oder über bestimmte Sachen reden zu können,
auch was positives hat, was gutes hat und so hat sich das so irgendwie manifestiert dann.
Immer lohnenswert, auch in so andere Sphären einzutauchen..
Seitdem ich irgendwie Buchhaltung richtig drauf habe, kann ich sogar auf einer Steuerberaterparty richtig Spaß haben.
Ja, das ist irgendwie genau.
Kontext ist immer wichtig.
Absolut.
Aber ist halt so dieses, ich meine, „Wissen macht Ah!“ und so die Maus und eben so Sesamstraße mit Abstrichen,
diese Einflüsse so aus dem Fernsehen haben es ja dann auch geschafft, so einen gewissen Kultstatus zu erlangen,
eben für die Nerds, also so für die Leute, oder sagen wir mal so, die Wissensliebhaber,
so die das irgendwie auch cool finden, dass die sportliche Ertüchtigung auch im Hirn stattfinden kann.
Im Prinzip ist ja, man sagt ja auch so Denksport, für viele Leute ist es dann nur so Kreuzworträtsel,
gut das trägt sicherlich auch dazu bei, sich da irgendwie so halbwegs fit zu halten.
Andere wollen es ja dann noch ein bisschen weiter treiben und in gewisser Hinsicht sind ja dann die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler sind ja so die Spitzensportler in diesem Feld, die dann eben auch wirklich noch das letzte rauskäsen wollen
und ich versage dann auch immer so ein bisschen dabei, insbesondere mit diesen ganzen mathematischen Exkursen,
die da zu durchlaufen sind, um dem Ganzen dann irgendwie noch den entsprechenden Rahmen zu bieten,
da noch irgendwie zu folgen, finde das aber natürlich dann auch toll.
Und es hat sich schon, denke ich, auch was verändert.
Wir hatten das ja auch in zahlreichen Sendungen immer wieder so am Rande die Feststellung,
Wissenschaft ist ja eigentlich was neues.
Es gibt den Beruf des Wissenschaftlers, der Wissenschaftlerin gibt es eigentlich so ja auch erst seit 100 Jahren.
Vorher gab es Leute, die waren halt in irgendeinem Feld vielleicht ganz gut oder so,
aber man hätte jetzt nie davon gesprochen, dass sozusagen das Erarbeiten von Wissen als solchem
an sich so einen Berufsstatus hat.
Früher gab es halt so diese Superhelden, so Galileo Galilei und so weiter,
die konnten ja alles mögliche, also so Maler und so Leonardo da Vinci,
der hat irgendwie Konstruktionen gemacht, hat Bilder gemalt und so weiter,
die haben sich halt einfach in vielen Bereichen getummelt, weil sie überall in irgendeiner Form ihre Fertigkeiten weiterentwickeln konnten
und so und waren natürlich dann so nebenbei eben auch bei dem ein oder anderen wissenschaftlichen Durchbruch beteiligt
und jetzt haben wir eigentlich erst seit 100 Jahren eben auch wirklich so dieses Berufsbild,
so eben so Spitzensportler des Denkens, so Wissenschaftler, Leute, die halt Wissen schaffen,
die einfach das so quasi wie in so einem Bergbau quasi immer wieder so aus dem Nichts herausklöppeln.
Und das ist natürlich dann auch etwas, was nach Vorbildern schreit, um eben auch Jugendlichen vor allem
oder überhaupt auch allen in der Gesellschaft zu zeigen, so ja das ist halt auch cool.
Die Klugscheißer sind halt eigentlich gar nicht so scheiße, sondern das ist eben auch etwas, was einen gesellschaftlichen Wert hat,
das ist auch etwas, was sozusagen herausragende Leistungen, auf die man stolz sein kann, schaffen kann,
die dann eben auch ihre Anerkennung erfahren.
Und ich habe immer so den Eindruck, in gewisser Hinsicht, obwohl da jetzt schon so viel passiert ist,
braucht es noch ein bisschen, um wirklich auch diesen Status anzunehmen.
In Teilen der Gesellschaft ist es sicherlich so, aber wir erleben ja auch gerade in dieser Corona-Krise da so ein Battle.
Da können wir sicherlich auch gleich noch mal drauf eingehen.
Vielleicht klappern wir noch mal eine andere Zwischenstation ab, weil das ja auch damit dann was zu tun hat,
du hast ja dann auch bei „Quarks & Co“ mitgemacht, was ja Ranga Yogeshwar ja so auch auf seine einmalige Art und Weise
auch so über einen längeren Zeitraum, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange das schon läuft.
Läuft jetzt auch über 25 Jahre.
Genau, also auch schon so gefühlte Ewigkeit.
Auch so mit seiner Art und Weise zu moderieren, ja auch sehr populär gemacht hat.
Noch mal ein anderer Style, immer sehr am Thema, aber eben, ich weiß gar nicht,
was würdest denn du sagen, was das Wesen dieser Sendung und den Erfolg dieser Sendung so ausmacht?
Naja, weniger die Unterhaltung, mehr so diese Tiefe, die es da immer gab und gibt.
Bei „Wissen macht Ah!“ beispielsweise oder auch bei der Sendung mit der Maus,
da gibt es ja in einer Sendung ganz viele verschiedene Themen.
Es gibt kein einzelnes Oberthema und das war bei Quarks halt immer so, es gab ein Oberthema
und alle möglichen Aspekte dieses einen Themas wurden bearbeitet.
Und da konnten schon gut in die Tiefe gehen und das war was sehr anspruchsvolles.
Und ich glaube, das war auch mit der große Erfolg.
Und gleichzeitig hat Ranga es immer geschafft und die Redaktion und die Autoren und Autorinnen,
das aber so runterzubrechen, dass man das auch verstehen konnte, wenn man nicht die ganze Vorbildung mitgebracht hat
und das war natürlich super.
Also dieses eigentlich immer bei null anfangen und nichts vorauszusetzen, das nimmt einen mit egal wo du bist.
Du kannst folgen und wenn dich das Thema interessiert, erfährst du noch viel mehr als du jemals hättest dir selbst anlesen können.
Und das ist das großartige dabei.
Es ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch was neues, weil das Fernsehen ja eigentlich immer sich auch sehr viel für so flüchtige Begegnungen mit Themen steht.
Dass Dinge nicht so vertieft werden, dass man auch versucht, sich an so eine Masse anzupassen
und dann der Kompromiss dann immer ist so, naja unser Wert ist ja quasi die Quantität der Wahrnehmung.
Wenn viele Leute es sehen, ist es automatisch gut versus dieses, naja es müssen nicht unbedingt viele sein,
aber wenn viele das verstehen, dann ist es gut.
Nur das lässt sich halt nicht so einfach messen.
Überhaupt nicht.
Und ich glaube, da war Ranga auch so richtig ja Vorreiter.
Also ähnlich wie Harald Lesch das immer noch macht, dass du, obwohl da nur jemand steht und redet,
hörst du halt gerne zu, weil irgendwie schafft er es so die Haken auszuwerfen, dass du dann hängenbleibst.
Ja.
Und das ist das tolle dabei.
Ich hatte, kann ich auch noch mal eine alte Sendung hier erwähnen, Forschergeist 55 habe ich mich mit Harald Lesch unterhalten
über die Kunst des Wissens, wie wir es am Ende genannt haben.
Dass es nämlich eben eine Kunst ist in gewisser Hinsicht, diese Wissensermittlung und -vermittlung in irgendeiner Form auch in eine gewisse Form zu bringen.
Absolut.
Also es ist eben nicht wie bei mir früher in der Schule im Geschichtsunterricht.
Du lernst nicht, wenn dich dein Lehrer einfach nur aus dem Buch vorlesen lässt, das ist super langweilig.
Da lernst du höchstens, wie man gut einschlafen kann, aber nichts über Geschichte.
Und genauso ist es eben auch beim Fernsehen, es muss einen Anfang, eine Mitte und ein Ende haben,
das, was man da erzählt bekommt.
Und das wird oft unterschätzt, das aber so wichtig ist.
Jetzt hat sich ja gerade dieses Quarks & Co Format auch mal gehäutet und sich neu entwickelt.
Du bist zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt da mit eingestiegen, ist auch schon ein paar Jahre, glaube ich, her.
Ja.
Mit so einem Nebenformat, so habe ich es wahrgenommen.
Ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, ehrlich gesagt, was da so das Ziel der Geschichte war?
Also es war so, dass die brauchten einfach so eine Art Urlaubsvertretung für Ranga.
Und ja, da wurde ich gefragt, ob ich das mache.
Sommerprogramm sozusagen.
Richtig, genau.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob die sich unsicher waren, ob ich das einigermaßen gute mache
oder ob die lieber da noch so eine Abgrenzung haben wollten,
jedenfalls haben die es dann nicht „Quarks & Co“ genannt, sondern „Quarks & Caspers“,
was ich ganz lustig fand, weil es ja eben praktisch fast genauso geschrieben wird, mit C zumindest.
Und dann haben wir da erst mal 2010 zwei Sendungen gemacht und die haben auch versucht,
was anderes zu machen, die wollten so eine Art Top 10 von irgendeinem Thema immer machen.
So dass wir so ein bisschen ein Thema hatten und da die 10 interessantesten Sachen.
War wie so ein bisschen Clickbait eigentlich.
Die 7 interessantesten Sachen über Verdauung beispielsweise.
Und so hat es sich dann weiter entwickelt und irgendwie lief das aber ganz okay
und dann ja ist „Quarks & Caspers“ ein fester Bestandteil geblieben.
Und dann irgendwann wurde das aber auch zu „Quarks & Co“, weil es klar war, das muss man nicht mehr so trennen.
Und irgendwann hat auch Quarks als Marke sich so konsolidiert, das heißt, es gab dann im Radio zum Beispiel,
da gab es „Leonardo“ beim WDR, das war sozusagen das Wissenschaftsformat, das wurde jetzt auch zu Quarks.
Und es gab ganz viele verschiedene Sachen, die dann unter Quarks plötzlich zusammengebracht worden sind
und da fiel das Co dann auch weg.
Jetzt ist es ja so, du hast mal vor ein paar Jahren auch auf einer Veranstaltung des Chaos Computers Club,
beim Chaos Communication Camp hast du einen Vortrag gehalten, auch so ähnlich wie wir jetzt hier gerade so sprechen über Wissensvermittlung etc.
und du hast es so eingeleitet mit, du hast ja eigentlich von nichts Ahnung.
Und jetzt gerade in dieser Quarks-Situation dann quasi so eine Moderationsrolle zu übernehmen von jemandem,
der irgendwie Elementarteilchenphysik und Astrophysik studiert hat und ja sozusagen immer auch aus so einem Knowing heraus seine Moderationen macht,
also quasi auch sein eigenes tief erworbenes Wissen runterbricht, um es verständlich zu machen.
Was einem ja, wenn man das kann, immer so eine absolute Versicherung auch geben kann,
ich weiß wovon ich rede so und bin mir jetzt extrem sicher.
Und diese Selbstsicherheit in so einem Satz unterzubringen ist, glaube ich, in der Wirkung auch nicht ganz unerheblich.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, du hast ja eigentlich von nichts Ahnung, dann würde ich das jetzt mal so ein bisschen übersetzen mit,
die Wissenschaft ist ja nicht im eigentlichen Sinne deine Expertise gewesen von Anfang an,
du bist nur quasi jetzt so herangeführt worden.
Ich bin da reingerutscht.
In diese Rolle der Vermittlung.
Wobei ich ja auch sagen würde, du hast dem ja sozusagen auch eine Expertise mitgegeben,
nur eben nicht der eigentlichen Wissenschaft.
Wenn du das jetzt bei Quarks machst, war das dann komisch?
Nö, weil auch da musste ich ja genau wie bei der Maus oder bei „Wissen macht Ah!“ erst mal für mich die Antwort klarkriegen.
Das gehört ja zu meiner Arbeit dazu.
Du musst lernen.
Mehr oder weniger ja.
Ich muss mir die Sachen durchlesen, die dann Autorinnen oder Autoren recherchiert haben,
muss selbst recherchieren und mit Leuten sprechen, damit ich sozusagen das alles, von dem ich keine Ahnung habe,
damit ich Ahnung bekomme und damit ich dann alles das wegschneiden kann, was für die eigentliche Erklärung nicht notwendig ist,
so dass ich im Grunde mit der einfachsten Form erst mal anfangen kann.
Die einfachste Form, die, auch wenn viel weggelassen worden ist, trotzdem noch richtig ist, das ist ja das A und O.
Das ist ja auch das schwierige, wenn wir zum Beispiel mit Forschenden sprechen
und die alle Aspekte ihrer Arbeit mit reinbringen wollen und alle kleinen Eventualitäten auch mit reinbringen wollen,
die aber für’s Fernsehen einfach, das hat keinen Platz, weil das dann zu ausufernd ist.
Und das ist, auch wenn es ein Wissenschaftsmagazin ist, es ist ja kein Peer Review eigentlich.
Es ist ja, wir stellen ja nur Forschungsarbeiten vor und versuchen, die Quintessenz da rauszuholen,
ohne noch auf alle anderen Möglichkeiten, welche Bedeutung das haben kann, hinzuweisen.
Vielleicht wenn wir Zeit haben, aber grundsätzlich ist es so, das, was eine Forscherin rausgefunden hat,
ist wie so ein großes Gebilde mit Skelett und viel Fleisch drumherum und Haaren.
Und das, was wir machen, ist, erst mal alles wegzunehmen, dass nur das Skelett da ist
und dann kann man noch gucken, wieviel von dem Rest können wir noch dazu packen,
damit es vielleicht noch ein bisschen voller wird.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen müssen wir erst mal uns auf das Skelett konzentrieren
und gucken dann, was wir zeitmäßig noch reinkriegen.
Wobei das ja vielleicht auf der eine Seite eine starke Anforderung des Fernsehens ist,
aber meiner Auffassung nach eigentlich auch schon generell eigentlich eine Anforderung des Erklärens als solches sein sollte.
Weil in dem Moment, wo man zu viele Details reinbringt, die dann schwierig zu verstehen sind,
weil sie noch mehr Kontext erfordern, also noch mehr Vorwissen erfordern,
macht man dann so den Kardinalfehler der Klugscheißer, an der Stelle die, die nerven,
dass selbst, wenn so ein bewusstes Wollen, so eine Bereitschaft ist, Information aufzunehmen,
man aber so überladen wird mit Informationen, die in dem Moment eigentlich gar nicht relevant sind,
und einem immer wieder dieses Gefühl geben, oh das müsste ich jetzt aber auch noch verstehen und so weiter
und irgendwann schaltet man dann halt total ab so.
Absolut.
Also ich persönlich nenne das immer ein bisschen so, man muss verstehen, was andere Leute nicht verstehen,
damit man irgendwas richtig erklären kann, damit man weiß, was man irgendwie weglassen kann.
Ja und du musst Mut zur Lücke haben.
Du musst jetzt nicht alles mögliche mit erklären, sondern nur das, was jetzt gerade wichtig ist.
Und dieser Mut zur Lücke, der fehlt viel, weil das natürlich auch angreifbar macht,
weil plötzlich jemand sagt, ja aber Moment mal, du hast ja nicht erklärt, wie jetzt das mit den Zotteln und so funktioniert.
Und da muss man einfach sagen, ja war jetzt aber auch nicht so wichtig für das, was ich eigentlich erklären wollte.
Darum ging es nicht.
Aber findest du auch, dass es so ein Erklärbär-Problem gibt in Deutschland, ich meine,
es gibt natürlich so ein paar Leuchttürme, wir haben jetzt auch so einige Leute genannt,
die gerade in letzter Zeit da vielleicht auch viel wieder wettgemacht haben,
aber ich kenne so ein bisschen diesen Amerikaner-Effekt, wenn man auf so Konferenzen geht
und dann hat man so zwei Vorträge von Deutschen und dann kommt irgendwie so ein Amerikaner und macht einen Vortrag
und das ist so wie Tag und Nacht irgendwie.
Die sind halt unterhaltsamer wahrscheinlich.
Ja das auf der einen Seite, aber da ist irgendwie ein ganz anderer Flow drin.
Ja, also ich glaube, da spielt total viel rein.
Erstens ist ja ganz wichtig Reizverknüpfung, das ist das was ich meine, das muss unterhaltsam sein,
also zumindest beim Fernsehen.
Und es hilft auch, wenn es so ein gewisse Art von innerer Komik vielleicht auch manchmal hat bei dem Vortragenden,
der dieses Thema so total in- und auswendig kann, also der es by heart kennt.
Und der wirklich so mit Herzblut auch dabei ist, weil es ihm Spaß macht.
Und wenn sich das vermittelt, dann ist das schon mal das A und O.
Das ist ja oft bei vielen meiner Lehrerinnen und Lehrer, dass ich oft mich gefragt habe,
warum haben die eigentlich sich dieses Fach ausgesucht?
Wo du dir denkst, da ist überhaupt keine Leidenschaft.
Wieso erwarten die von mir Leidenschaft für ihr Fach, wenn sie es selbst nicht mal haben?
Also dieses Herzblut ist ganz wichtig.
Dass man eben auch versucht, das Thema mit anderen Reizen zu verknüpfen.
Also ein guter Reiz ist Humor, wenn du etwas lustig findest und lachen musst,
dann kannst du dir wahrscheinlich das, was gerade noch vermittelt wurde, viel besser merken.
Was du ja eben auch gesagt hast, das mit dem Suspicious.
Wenn dein Lehrer sich da an die Tafel stellt und irgendwie einen pantomimischen Ziegelstein in der Hand hoch und runter wirft,
das prägt sich einfach ein, das ist eine klassische Reizverknüpfung irgendwie und das ist total wichtig,
so was auch auszunutzen, dass unser Gehirn so funktioniert.
Und dann kommt noch ein Sache dazu, die glaube ich hier in Deutschland total unterschätzt wird,
aber im englischsprachigen Bereich Gang und Gäbe ist, das ist so was wie, jeder kann lernen Geschichten zu erzählen.
Es gibt Creative Writing Classes und das ist bei uns, glaube ich, immer noch so,
dass man davon ausgeht, dass nur derjenige Geschichten wirklich gut erzählen kann,
der irgendwie so ein gewisses Naturtalent mitbringt oder von der Muse geküsst ist,
aber dass es einfach Handwerkskunst ist, das ist vielen gar nicht klar.
Dass man es lernen kann, wie man Geschichten schreiben kann, wissen, glaube ich, die meisten gar nicht.
Und dass man bestimmte Samen pflanzen kann am Anfang der Geschichte und die kann man dann am Ende ernten
und plötzlich wird das so was ganz rundes, das sind einfach …
So wie John Oliver das auf beste Art und Weise immer wieder macht.
Ja beispielsweise, und das ist einfach Handwerk, das ist kein Buch mit sieben Siegeln, was nur eingeweihte bekommen,
die mit Blut unterschrieben haben, sondern das ist nachlesbar.
Techniken sind das ja.
Und so was ist total wichtig, das ist auch für Wissensvermittlung total wichtig,
einfach damit auch die, die zuhören, dabei bleiben und …
Ja und da frage ich mich halt immer, inwiefern unser Bildungssystem da noch Reformbedarf nachweist.
Mir ist auch mal so ein Amerikaner … ich weiß es nicht mehr so ganz genau, aber ich glaube,
ich habe ihn dann auch gefragt, was er macht und er sagte, er studiert Standup Comedy war es, glaube ich.
Oder vielleicht hieß der Kurs noch ein bisschen anders, aber sozusagen die Vorstellung, dass man Humor studieren kann, in Deutschland …
Unerhört.
Also was erlaube.
Also das gibt es halt hier nicht, sondern das ist alles so hoch aufgehängt und muss immer in irgendwas mystischem eingebettet sein
und man lernt immer universell und nicht so, dass man auch mal so eine vertikale zielgerichtete Sache einfach mal direkt verfolgt.
Muss ja auch nicht das einzige bleiben, was man macht, aber dann könnte man dann wahrscheinlich sich auch sehr viel mehr drauf konzentrieren
als dann immer gleich so einen kompletten Kosmos mitvermittelt zu bekommen, der einen in dem Moment gar nicht interessiert.
Und Creative Writing klingt ähnlich.
Absolut, das sind so Übungen im Grunde, wie du so Schreibblockaden überwinden kannst im einfachsten Fall.
Und das ist aber so ein weites Feld, wichtig ist, jeder kann lernen, wie man Geschichten schreibt und wie man Sachen erzählt.
Und wenn du das weißt, wenn du so ein paar Grundkniffe kennst, dann ist plötzlich so ein Vortrag,
hast du dann auch Möglichkeiten, ganz anders ranzugehen.
Also ich finde es ja immer grausam, wenn ich manche wissenschaftlichen Vorträge sehe,
wo die einzelnen Slides so vollgeballert sind mit Text und so klein, dass du es gar nicht mehr erkennen kannst.
Wo du dir denkst, warum sagst du jetzt genau das gleiche, was ich da lesen kann, das ist ja völlig unsinnig.
Du solltest ja deine Slides ergänzen oder andersrum, deine Slides sollten dich ergänzen,
aber das soll ja nicht redundant sein, soll ja nicht das gleiche sein, nur in einer anderen Form,
sondern du stehst da, weil ich dir zuhöre, und die Slides unterstützen das im besten Fall.
Und dass das aber bei so vielen Vorträgen immer noch nicht da ist, das finde ich echt hart.
Und das ist wirklich bei ganz vielen englischsprachigen Speakern anders, glaube ich,
die haben es irgendwie anders gelernt oder anders mitbekommen.
Es hat glaube ich viel damit zu tun, dass in den Schulen dieses Präsentieren einfach einen großen Raum einnimmt.
Vielleicht.
Dass das von den Schülern sehr früh schon abverlangt wird und gut, man weiß jetzt nicht, was das eine und das andere bedingt,
aber natürlich ist diese ganze Showmanship und dieses Entertainment ist ein riesiger Exportschlager eigentlich auch der USA,
dass sie es halt einfach geschafft haben, so Unterhaltung als solche irgendwie auch wirklich fassbar zu machen
und auf eine Art und Weise unterhaltsam zu sein, dass es schon fast industriellen Rahmen hat.
Von daher spielt es natürlich da eine andere Rolle und bei uns ist das halt einfach nicht so.
Und es ist halt eigentlich, ich will jetzt nicht, dass wir jetzt gleich unbedingt mit derselben Oberflächlichkeit dann auch auftreten,
wie das ja dann oft auch so ein Nebeneffekt ist, aber dass das dem Präsentieren, dem selber tun und dem selber auch Vorlieben sozusagen dann auch zu berücksichtigen,
mehr Raum eingeräumt wird, ist glaube ich erforderlich.
Was du sagst so mit diesen Nebenreizen, ich meine, es ist ja zum Beispiel auch so ein Erfolgsfaktor bei Podcasts, ja,
weil man eben einfach nur Hörmaterial erzeugt, was sich wunderbar so nebenbei weghören lässt,
kann man es ja wunderbar mit anderen Aktivitäten machen.
Also ich merke das immer wieder, wenn ich gerade so an neuen Orten bin, Urlaub oder so
oder man fährt halt überhaupt mal in eine Stadt, wo man noch nicht war, und dann laufe ich gerne mal einfach zwei Stunden nur durch die Stadt
und höre dabei einen Podcast und kann mich meistens Jahre später noch daran erinnern,
an welcher Straßenecke ich gerade welches Thema gehört habe, weil sich einfach das Bild und der Ton in dem Moment irgendwie paart.
Und ähnlich muss man es dann, glaube ich, an der Stelle machen, da hat das Fernsehen natürlich auch ein hohes Potenzial an Wirkmächtigkeit es richtig zu machen,
aber natürlich auch eine ganze Menge falsch zu machen.
Sagt dir zum Beispiel das Format Pecha Kucha, deutscher ausgesprochen Pecha Kucha, etwas?
Das sind alle 20 Sekunden ein neuer Slide.
Genau, das ist nämlich so ein Präsentationsform, bei dem überhaupt gar keine Texte sind,
also man könnte welche haben, aber man hat halt eben die Slides und die stehen halt wirklich,
also 20 Bilder á 20 Sekunden festgelegte Länge etc. und man muss dann sich auf einmal darauf takten
und das fand ich, ich habe das mal gemacht, ich fand das großartig, weil das einfach ganz andere Dynamik aufzwingt
und darüber das ganz gut lernen kann.
Das ist sowieso bei Kreativität, also ich habe festgestellt, je starrer das Korsett ist,
sei es jetzt finanziell, weil du nicht viel Geld hast, sei es jetzt so was zeitmäßiges,
dass du alle 20 Sekunden eine neue Slide machen musst.
Also bei mir ist es so, desto kreativer wird man, weil man plötzlich anfangen muss,
innerhalb dieses Rahmens zu spielen und man kann nicht komplett frei rumspinnen,
sondern du bist halt so ein bisschen beschränkt, das ist immer eine große Hilfe ehrlich gesagt.
Kommen wir noch mal ein bisschen auf das Fernsehen, weil ich finde ja Fernsehen hat ja auch so ein bisschen seine Grenzen.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich einige Beispiele genannt, wo diese Grenzen vielleicht dann auch mal ein bisschen aufgeweicht wurden,
aber dieses Aufbereiten für ein Publikum heißt ja, in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein Gefühl dafür zu haben,
was dieses Publikum eigentlich ist oder will.
Man sieht es aber halt nicht.
Also inwiefern spielt jetzt da eine innere Vorstellung eine größere Rolle oder habt ihr da auch ein Feedbackflow in irgendeiner Form,
dass ihr sagen könntet, wir kennen dieses Publikum auch und wir wissen, was die wollen.
Weil es ist ja immer schwierig, so den Erfolg zu messen, hatten wir ja vorhin schon,
quantitativ geht das wunderbar, aber qualitativ ist es schwierig und umso mehr man eben so auf Wissen und Verständnis geht,
müsste man ja eigentlich so was auch überprüfen.
Was für eine Art Herangehensweise siehst du da?
Gute Frage, weil ich überhaupt keine Ahnung davon habe.
Also tatsächlich ist es so, dass ich …
Also ich versuche es immer so zu machen, dass ich es erst mal selbst gut finde.
Und versuche auch, wenn ich zum Beispiel Sachen vertone, das so zu machen,
dass ich der ganzen Sache gut folgen kann.
Jetzt an Rückkanälen das läuft ja meistens alles bei den Redaktionen auf, da bin ich nicht jeden Tag.
Also das ist so, die versuchen das irgendwie umzusetzen und zu bearbeiten.
Und natürlich gibt es auch Marktforschung und Zielgruppenerforschung und so was,
aber ich bin da eher ein bisschen skeptisch.
Ich finde, wenn so was wie Marktforschung wirklich funktionieren würde, dann gäbe es nicht so viel Scheiße im Fernsehen.
Und deshalb …
… verlässt du dich eher auf die Intuition?
Ja, genau, ich verlasse mich eher darauf, was mir gefällt.
Ich weiß aber auch, dass ich Glück hatte in den letzten Jahren, dass das, was mir gefällt, einer respektablen Zahl an Zuschauenden eben auch gefallen hat.
Aber woher weißt du das?
Weil ich es immer noch mache.
Naja okay gut.
Weil sonst würde ich ja auch weg vom Fenster sein.
Und ich weiß ganz genau, das kann aber morgen passieren oder übermorgen,
dass ich plötzlich Sachen gut finde, die aber die meisten vielleicht gar nicht mehr gut finden
und das ist ja immer so das Risiko, das man hat, wenn man so ein bisschen auf Intuition fährt
und versucht, diese ganzen Forschungsergebnisse, die es gibt, vielleicht zu ignorieren.
Oft sind ja solche Medienforschungssachen für die Redaktion einfach nur so ein Zahlenkonstrukt,
was in den Hierarchien weitergereicht werden kann, dass man sagen kann, ja aber die Medienforschung sieht das so und so
und insofern sind wir fein raus, das hat die Forschung ergeben.
Und das ist manchmal ein bisschen, ich glaube, dass es sich dann vielleicht ein bisschen leicht gemacht wird, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber gibt es nicht mittlerweile durch Internet und Social Media und diese ganzen Rückkanäle…
Klar gibt es da auch Sachen.
… die da neu entstanden sind, mehr Rückmeldung?
Das ist auch ganz nett, aber auch da weißt du ja, meistens melden sich die Leute zurück, die sich …
… die was zu meckern haben, ja.
… die sich irgendwie aufgeregt haben.
Also es kostet wirklich sehr viel Community-Management, um diese zarten Pflänzchen, die einfach diskutieren wollen,
um die groß werden zu lassen, ohne dass die kaputt getrampelt werden von irgendwelchen Trollen.
Und da entwickelt sich dann auch total viel schönes.
Also wir haben zum Beispiel für Quarks so eine Reihe gemacht über das Universum
und über das Gehirn und die Fragen und Gedanken, die da aufkommen, das ist wirklich toll, das mitzukriegen,
was auch in den Köpfen von denen vorgeht, die da zusehen, das inspiriert auch und gibt neue Themen
und man kann sich unterhalten über das, was man so gesagt hat, was im Fernsehen nicht möglich ist, das ist echt super.
Aber da jetzt draus zu schließen, dass ich jetzt anhand dieser Unterhaltungen wissen könnte,
was das nächste große Thema ist, was alle interessiert, das ist, glaube ich, ja da macht man sich was vor, wenn man das denkt.
Ja, ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es einfach ist, es ist auf jeden Fall eine Herausforderung, die man hat
und manche machen, glaube ich, mehr, haben mehr Bereitschaft, da sozusagen auch so in diesen Diskurs,
in diese offene Diskussion, in diesen Internetdiskurs reinzugehen, was definitiv schwierig ist durch die Trollproblematik
und eben wie du sagst, dass viele Leute erst mal was, eigentlich immer nur auf was reagieren, was falsch ist.
Ich mache das oft dann halt so, wenn jemand was schlimmes behauptet oder so, dann gebe ich das halt einfach wider und sage,
jemand behauptet, dass das und das so und so ist, woraufhin dann andere darauf reagieren,
weil das ist ja dann auch wieder aus ihrer Position dann wiederum falsch und dann haben sie etwas, worüber sie sich beschweren können.
Ja. Also was natürlich auf jeden Fall klappt, das haben wir auch gesehen, ist so Microtargeting,
dass du weißt, mit dem du es zu tun hast im Großen und Ganzen und denen dann entsprechend die Inhalte geben kannst,
die sie interessieren vermeintlich oder die zumindest dafür sorgen, dass sie lange dabei bleiben.
Also Facebook macht das ja ganz großartig, kann man gut finden oder auch nicht, ich finde es eher zweifelhaft.
Ich finde es auch immer schön, Sachen zu bekommen, mit denen ich überhaupt nicht gerechnet habe,
weil das deinen Horizont erweitert und du hast nicht diesen Tunnelblick und guckst immer nur auf das eine Dinge,
wie so ein Reh auf der Straße, was immer auf die Scheinwerfer schaut.
Genau, das ist ja diese Selbstverstärkung, die uns ja auch eine ganze Menge üble Debatten gebracht haben.
Das bringt mich tatsächlich genau auf den Punkt, auf den ich jetzt eigentlich noch so hinaus wollte,
nämlich der Status von Wissen, jetzt haben wir schon viel über den Wert von Wissen und wie der so in der Gesellschaft reflektiert wird gesprochen,
was so wie cool oder nicht cool jetzt klugscheißen ist.
Jetzt haben wir durch diese Corona-Krise auf einmal so eine Bewegung gehabt,
wo auf einmal Wissenschaft eine existentielle Rolle auf einmal übernommen hat.
Und während ich mal unterstellen würde, dass es sicherlich noch einen Großteil der Gesellschaft,
der auch bereit ist, diesem Wissen zu folgen und daraus für sich auch entsprechende Handlungsempfehlungen abzuleiten,
sehen wir natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch eine ganze Menge Leute, die einfach mit einer generellen Skepsis dem begegnen.
Jetzt finde ich es grundsätzlich nicht falsch, wenn man Dingen skeptisch gegenüber steht,
das ist in vielen Bereichen auch absolut wichtig und sicherlich auch, was die Wissenschaft betrifft,
zumal ja die Wissenschaft auch selber von sich eigentlich im Idealfall niemals behauptet, die Wahrheit zu kennen,
sondern halt immer nur einen aktuellen Stand, der irgendwie beliebig nahe an dieser Wahrheit sein kann,
der sich aber auch täglich ändern kann, was ja dann der Wissenschaft auch vorgeworfen wird,
ja aber gestern habt ihr ja noch das behauptet, ja da haben wir das ja noch nicht gewusst und so.
Das ist ein schwieriger Diskurs, der sich da entwickelt hat.
Bei Corona wurde es ja erst mal so richtig deutlich, dass Wissenschaft ein Prozess ist.
Das ist nicht, das ist jetzt das Buch mit allen Antworten und weiter geht es nicht,
sondern da wird halt immer weiter dran gefeilt und gearbeitet.
Und ja, was am Montag Stand der Wissenschaft ist, muss nicht am Freitag auch noch Stand der Wissenschaft sein.
Und das wurde, glaube ich, zum ersten Mal einer breiten Masse klar, und damit muss man erst mal zurechtkommen,
dass eben Wissenschaft nicht der Weisheit letzter Schluss ist, sondern im Grunde nur ein Schritt dahin.
Aber ich habe dich unterbrochen, Entschuldigung.
Ja nein, genau darüber wollte ich halt reden.
Ich meine, ich habe es tatsächlich an der Quarks-Redaktion so ein bisschen wahrgenommen,
vielleicht kannst du das bestätigen, vielleicht war es ja auch anders, aber ich hatte so den Eindruck,
die sind ja dann mit so einigen Produktionen auch im Netz unterwegs gewesen, Videos gemacht so,
wo sie irgendwie so, hier ist jetzt auch mal so unser aktueller Blick auf die Dinge
und sind auch, glaube ich, auf diese Wissenschaftsskeptiker, -leugner etc. ein Stück weit eingegangen,
einfach eben durch einerseits das Nachlegen von Fakten, aber ich hatte auch so den Eindruck,
dass die nicht nur so im Sinne von, und hier unsere neueste Produktion über Wissenschaft
und ach Corona-Krise ist das nicht schön, gucken wir mal was wir alles wissen,
sondern das ist schon so eine gewisse, ich weiß nicht wie ich es nennen soll,
Alarmierung vielleicht auch schon so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf war, so nach dem Motto,
jetzt geht es hier aber auch wirklich mal ums Ganze, jetzt ist es nicht nur so, ich weiß was oder ich weiß es nicht
und wenn ich es nicht weiß, ist auch egal.
Das ist nicht nur so ein Angebot, sondern man hatte wirklich so den Eindruck,
die sehen sich so einem Feind gegenüber, wo man mal eine Barrikade aufziehen muss.
Jetzt bin ich in so militärischen Worten, soweit ich ich es gar nicht machen.
Aber halt einfach sozusagen auch ein bewusstes Statement zu setzen und sagen so,
nein Leute, jetzt müsst ihr aber auch wirklich mal langsam mal was verstehen, /unverständlich/
Ich glaube, es war tatsächlich jetzt gerade bei Corona so, dass es klar wurde,
wir brauchen jetzt jemanden, der uns die Sachen erklärt, der sagt, was ist denn der aktuelle Stand der Wissenschaft
und wie verhalte ich mich jetzt, Mundschutz ja oder nein?
Jemand, der Ahnung hat oder von dem man zumindest denkt, ja die beschäftigen sich seit Jahren schon mit wissenschaftlichen Themen,
die müssen doch Ahnung haben.
Und da kamen ganz viele Anfragen an Quarks auch und man hat gemerkt,
okay der WDR und auch die ARD war froh, dass es so eine Wissenschaftsredaktion gab
oder mehrere Wissenschaftsredaktionen, die alle dazu beitragen konnten, dieses große komplexe Problem so ein bisschen aufzubrechen
und in leicht verdaulichen Happen wieder zu präsentieren, damit eben Leute,
die sich nicht täglich damit auseinandersetzen, trotzdem verstehen um was es geht.
Und das ist ja ganz wichtig, dass du verstehst um was es geht, damit eben diese Situation so schnell wie möglich vorbeigehen kann.
Denn wenn du es schaffst zum Beispiel, die Ansteckungsrate gering zu halten,
dann bedeutet das, dass eben auch die Pandemie schnell vorbei ist.
Wenn du es schaffst, Leute zu impfen, dann sorgst du auch dafür, dass sich nicht wieder mehr Leute anstecken,
das heißt, die Pandemie geht schneller vorbei und das ist ja genau das um was es geht.
Wir wollen aus der Situation wieder rauskommen und das geht nur mit Hilfe von Wissen, wie ich mich am besten verhalten kann.
Und denkst du, dass das erfolgreich war?
Ja. Ich glaube, du musst dir nur mal vorstellen, was passiert wäre, wenn es das nicht gegeben hätte.
Ich glaube, dann wären wir jetzt wahrscheinlich an einem ganz anderen Punkt.
Tot zum Beispiel.
Tot.
Ja.
Ja oder auf dem Bauch liegend in irgendeinem Bett in der Intensivstation.
Und auch das ist ja auch so ein Ding, dass die Patienten, die beatmet werden, dann irgendwann auf dem Bauch liegen,
weil das dann für die Lunge besser ist.
Auch Sachen, die man am Anfang der Pandemie noch gar nicht so überall gesehen hat.
Das wurde dann schnell klar, dass das einfach hilfreich ist beispielsweise.
Wo hast du denn dein Wissen her bezogen?
Also wir haben ja für die Sendung mit der Maus sehr viele Corona-Fragen von den jüngeren Zuschauern beantwortet.
Und es gibt eine, in der Redaktion haben wir das so gemacht, dass wir uns das ein bisschen aufgeteilt haben.
Die Katrin Kreft, die auch viel für Quarks arbeitet, ist Ärztin und die weiß, wen sie fragen kann
und wie man Sachen lesen muss und hat mir im Grunde die Sachen erklärt und ich habe immer wieder nachgefragt,
wenn ich was nicht verstanden habe und so habe ich mich dran getastet an die Antworten, die ich dann geschrieben habe.
Und ich habe dann meine Antworten geschrieben und bevor ich die aufgenommen habe, habe ich es noch mal Katrin gezeigt
und sie hat gesagt, ja, so kannst du es genauso machen oder da ist noch was, was nicht so richtig gut erklärt ist,
da müsstest du noch mal ran, weil das so und so ist.
Und so ist es eigentlich immer Teamarbeit gewesen, also sowohl das Lernen als auch das Schreiben
oder das noch mal durchlesen.
Und hat das was verändert so?
Also du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, der WDR oder überhaupt der öffentliche Rundfunk war jetzt ganz froh,
eine Wissenschaftsredaktion zu haben, vielleicht hatte man diesen Eindruck vorher nicht unbedingt immer,
dass man immer so froh darüber ist, eine Wissenschaftsredaktion zu haben, weil es halt nicht so der Chartbreaker ist
und nicht in dieser Quantität immer gearbeitet hat, sondern eben mal versucht hat, mit einer Qualität zu arbeiten,
das ist ja also so ein bisschen ein Widerspruch und dann entdeckt man auf einmal so, oha…
Da haben wir ein ganz schönes Pfund im Haus.
Genau, das ist gut, dass wir die noch nicht alle rausgeschmissen haben.
Weil das wäre ja dann doch eine schlechte Idee gewesen.
Ändert das was langfristig, mittelfristig?
Gute Frage, ich hoffe, dass es was ändert in dem Sinne, dass so die Anerkennung der Arbeit weiter anhält,
auch wenn die Pandemie vorbei ist, dass klar ist, es ist gut, dass wir jemanden haben,
der uns Wissenschaften erklären kann und näher bringen kann, so als Schnittstelle zwischen den Forschenden und dem Publikum.
Damit man weiß, ah okay, in die Richtung geht die Forschung und das ist wichtig, weil so und so.
Und dass wir so was haben, ist einfach extrem wichtig.
Und denkst du, dass es dann auch gesamtgesellschaftlich auch …
Also ich weiß nicht, wie siehst du das, wie Wissen und Wissenschaft halt, aber reduzieren wir mal auf den Wert des Wissens als solchen,
also die Klugscheißer quasi, welche Stellenwert das in der Gesellschaft hat und haben müsste
und wo es sich hinentwickelt?
Weil ich glaube, viele Leute haben einfach jetzt gerade so ein bisschen auch die Angst,
das ist natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen das Problem der lauten Beschwerer,
die alles mögliche anzweifeln und beklagen, die natürlich schon viele anderen Leute verunsichern
und dann jetzt einfach generell den Klugscheißern so eine Skepsis entgegenbringen,
die es dann teilweise unmöglich macht, einfach auf so einer Faktenbasis zu argumentieren.
Also ich glaube, da muss man zweigleisig fahren wahrscheinlich.
Einerseits das machen, was wir sonst auch immer machen, nämlich den aktuellen Stand der Forschung darstellen,
und erzählen, in welche Richtung die Reise geht.
Und das zweite, was genauso wichtig ist, ist vielleicht so ein bisschen wissenschaftliches Arbeiten auch so zu vermitteln,
wie das funktioniert, sprich, nach welchen Kriterien kann ich eigentlich sagen, dass jemand Ahnung von etwas hat oder auch nicht?
Also hat derjenige vielleicht Arbeiten veröffentlicht zum Klima oder ist der eigentlich nur Verkehrswissenschaftler
und ist der eigentlich befähigt dazu, zu dem Thema was zu sagen oder ist eigentlich sein Fachgebiet ein ganz anderes
und nur weil er einen Doktor hat denken wir, der kann auch dazu was sagen.
Und das ist, glaube ich, ganz wichtig, dass man diesen Schritt zurückgeht und guckt,
okay wer kann jetzt was zu welchem Thema sagen und das ist auch wirklich glaubwürdig und glaubhaft und der hat wirklich Ahnung davon?
Und dieses Gefühl zu vermitteln, dass man das auch selbst rausfinden kann, dass es da auch Kriterien gibt,
die man anwenden kann, das ist, glaube ich, so der nächste Schritt, der wichtig ist, neben dem puren Vermitteln von Forschungsergebnissen
und wissenschaftlichem Arbeiten, dass man als Zuschauer oder Zuschauerin merkt,
ah okay, der redet jetzt über, keine Ahnung, Virologie, ist aber eigentlich in einem ganz anderen Bereich tätig
und hat vielleicht von Viren gar nicht so die Ahnung, dann ist es vielleicht auch gar nicht so richtig was der sagt,
vor allem wenn es nicht vielleicht dem wissenschaftlichen Konsens entspricht, sondern aus einer ganz anderen Richtung kommt.
Und das ist, glaube ich, ganz wichtig, dass man das Leuten auch so ein bisschen vermittelt.
Aber ich glaube, die Leute vertrauen dann quasi diesen Außenseitern.
Komischerweise.
Ja, einfach weil sie den anderen Experten misstrauen.
Da ist halt ein generelles Misstrauen gegenüber den Leuten, die eigentlich das richtige wissen sollten,
weil man es ja auch selber gar nicht so gut bewerten kann, weil man vielleicht auch persönlich ein anderes Verhältnis zu Bildung hat
und dem Wert von Bildung hat.
Was ja auch dazu kommt ist im Sinne einer ausgewogenen Berichterstattung und das habe ich jetzt in Anführungszeichen gesetzt,
wird dann ein Wissenschaftler eingeladen, der den Konsens vertritt und ein…
Man muss ja auch die andere Seite hören.
… ein anderer, der sozusagen aus der anderen Seite kommt und die bekommen zum Beispiel gleiche Redezeit.
Und dann denkt man, okay ich habe zwei unterschiedliche Ergebnisse, zwei Meinungen,
die werden gleichstark gefeatured, also kann ich mir aussuchen, für welche ich mich entscheide.
Aber tatsächlich ist es ja so, der wissenschaftliche Konsens, das müssten eigentlich tausend Wissenschaftler sein,
die diese Redezeit bekommen und der eine müsste dann eben nur ein tausendstel dieser Redezeit bekommen.
Und dieses Ungleichgewicht das wird gar nicht bedacht eigentlich bei der ausgewogenen Berichterstattung,
die eben nicht ausgewogen ist, weil der Konsens viel zu kurz kommt.
Wenn du jetzt aber jemanden hast, bist auf einer Party und hundert Leute sagen dir,
der Kuchen schmeckt super, den musst du essen und einer sagt, lass ja die Finger davon,
ich habe so Durchfall bekommen, dann denkst du, ja aber hundert Leute sagen, der ist gut,
also probiere ich den natürlich, wenn du aber nur zwei Leute hast und einer sagt, der ist super, da passiert nichts
und der andere sagt, da musst du echt wahnsinnig lange aufs Klos gehen danach, da wäre ich auch vorsichtig,
weil ich sage, okay, das sind jetzt zwei Leute, ich bleibe besser mal vorsichtig und skeptisch und probiere nichts von dem Kuchen.
Und das passiert eben auch im Fernsehen ganz oft bei Talkshows, dass dann zwei Leute eingeladen werden,
wo eigentlich hundert von dem einen und die Gegenmeinung da sein müssten,
dann würde das auch einen ganz anderen Eindruck machen.
Und wie geht ihr da so fernsehintern damit um?
Also ich meine, das ist doch sicherlich auch eine Debatte, die da geführt wird.
Ja, das sind ja unterschiedliche Redaktionen.
Ich weiß, aber ihr seid da ja schon, ist ja auch eine Szene irgendwie, man redet ja sicherlich auch mal miteinander oder auf die eine oder andere Weise?
Ich hoffe.
Also ich kann ja nur für uns sprechen, weil ich tatsächlich nicht weiß, ob die Redakteure untereinander reden,
Aber wir versuchen, das genauso zu machen, dass wir eigentlich immer den Konsens abbilden.
Und zu dem Konsens gehört auch zu sagen, wo es Unsicherheiten gibt und wo man nicht genau sagen kann,
dass es so und so ist und dass man das auch eben sagt, dass man das transparent macht,
wo es eben noch Unklarheiten gibt, wir versuchen aber nicht…
Ihr habt noch nicht den Telefonhörer angerufen und die ganzen Polittalksendungen mal abtelefoniert?
Also ich nicht.
Ja, wäre vielleicht mal eine ganz gute Idee.
Ich meine, es ist das Feedback sozusagen, was aus dem eigenen Haus in Anführungsstrichen kommt,
hat ja dann oft auch noch mal ein anderes Gewicht.
Ich will mich nicht beklagen, aber …
Das stimmt natürlich.
… das wäre sicherlich mal zu erwägen.
Zumal ich eben schon glaube, dass jetzt so oder so, haben wir ja schon drüber gesprochen,
quasi so die Wissenschaftsredaktionen jetzt auch schon mit einem gewissen Bonus aus dieser Geschichte herausgehen.
Weil im Großen und ganzen ich auch finde, dass gute Arbeit geleistet worden ist und wirklich viele Sachen,…
Ich meine, wer heute noch behauptet, man wüsste ja nicht oder es wird einem ja nicht erzählt, dass…
Ja nein, es ist eigentlich alles wirklich fünfmal und zwanzigmal erzählt worden
und auch durch so ein mediales Phänomen wie diesen Coronavirus Update Podcast,
sicherlich mit Christian Droste auch so ein Glücksfall der Geschichte.
Ja absolut, wie jemand das wirklich wirklich gut durchdrungen hat das Thema und das auf das Wesentliche reduzieren kann,
aber auch keine Angst davor hat, mal kurz einen Exkurs zu machen, um das noch mal ein bisschen genauer darzustellen.
Und du kannst super folgen, er benutzt Wörter, die jeder Mensch so auch benutzen würde.
Also oft ist es ja so, wenn du dich mit Experten unterhältst, dann denke ich zumindest, es klingt wie Deutsch,
aber irgendwie habe ich nichts verstanden und das hat er super drauf gehabt, fand ich.
Ja und ist ja auch noch unterwegs, hat ja auch nicht aufgehört, was ja sicherlich auch nicht ganz einfach war bei dem Gegenwind,
den man dann bekommt.
Weil das ja dann auch noch so ein negativer Effekt ist.
Vielleicht kannst du dazu auch noch mal was sagen, wie das so ist, dann eigentlich durch diese Formate so in der Öffentlichkeit zu stehen
und ja dann auch für etwas zu stehen, ist sicherlich nicht immer von Vorteil.
Also ehrlich gesagt habe ich, glaube ich, Glück.
Ich war zum Beispiel, ich habe mal den Bundeswettbewerb für Jugend forscht moderiert, die Preisverleihung zusammen mit Shary.
Und es war vor ein paar Jahren und wir waren anderthalb Tage vorher da, um uns die Projekte anzuschauen,
um mal durch diese, das ist wie so eine Messe aufgebaut, wo alle, die bei dem Wettbewerb mitmachen,
eben ihre Projekte aufbauen und zeigen, an was sie geforscht haben.
Und wir sind da rumgegangen, haben uns alles angeschaut, haben mit den Leuten gesprochen
und es war wirklich echt total großartig, weil 80 Prozent gesagt haben, ich bin nur hier wegen euch.
Und das ist natürlich ja also ein größeres Kompliment kann man gar nicht kriegen.
Ich weiß natürlich auch, dass die, auch wenn es uns nicht gegeben hätte, hätten die trotzdem ihren Weg gefunden
und wären da gewesen, aber dass sie ihre Forschungsarbeiten und ihr Interesse an Wissenschaft mit unserem Fernsehprogramm
und mit uns in Verbindung bringen, das ist natürlich ganz toll.
Das ist ein Geschenk, klar, weil ihr halt die Klugscheißer cool gemacht habt so, das ist sicherlich …
Also es mag dazu beigetragen haben, dass sie nicht von ihrem Weg abgebracht wurden durch externe Faktoren.
Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn wir dann so ein Thema haben bei Quarks über zum Beispiel SUVs,
warum werden die Autos immer größer und nehmen immer mehr Platz weg, dann ist auch klar,
das ist ein Thema das spaltet die Geister.
Da gibt es Leute, die denken sich, ja das ist doch auch eine Ausdrucksform mit welchem Auto ich fahre
und ich brauche das, um eben bequem ein- und aussteigen zu können und so weiter und so fort.
Und in der Sendung haben wir halt genau diese Argumente auch aufgenommen und gezeigt,
ja, es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten, du musst nicht so eine riesige Karre haben, die alles zustellt.
Aber da ist auch klar, das ist total emotional und da gibt es richtig viel böse Post dann darauf.
Da hilft nur, dass du weißt, die Sendung ist nach bestem Gewissen vorbereitet, alle Fakten sind überprüft worden von vielen verschiedenen Leuten,
dass das, was wir da erzählen, auch wirklich aktueller Stand der Forschung ist und so eine Wahrhaftigkeit hat,
die, auch wenn sie gefühlt nicht richtig ist, trotzdem Bestand hat.
Und das hilft, sich eben nicht verrückt machen zu lassen von den Leuten, die dann anfangen zu schimpfen.
Jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip schon bei dem nächsten großen Ding, also nach der Corona-Krise ist natürlich jetzt der Klimawandel voll in den Fokus geraten,
nicht nur durch die Bundestagswahl, sondern natürlich auch durch die ganzen immer weiteren Verschlimmerungen der Gesamtsituation.
Und ja ich habe so den Eindruck, der Übergang ist fließend.
Also so wie man sich jetzt um die Corona-Krise gekümmert hat, also jetzt aus der Perspektive der wissenschaftlichen Redaktionen heraus
gilt es jetzt eigentlich beim Klimawandel auf dieselbe Art und Weise nach zu legen und solche Zusammenhänge klarzumachen,
aber man macht sich damit ja auch Feinde von Leuten, die es eben, weiß ich nicht, nicht wahrhaben wollen,
oder vielleicht auch einfach nicht verstehen oder eben sich in ihrer persönlichen Ausdrucksform eingeschränkt fühlen,
was ja dann solche Abwehrreaktionen hervorbringt.
Ich meine, es sind ja teilweise auch wirklich vollkommen absurde Postionen.
Auch in der Corona-Krise hat man das gesehen, letztlich gingen im Netz halt so alte Fernsehberichte rum,
Interviews mit Leuten, als die Gurtanschnallpflicht eingeführt wurde.
Dieselben Ausreden im Prinzip wirklich nur noch mal mit einer anderen Farbe, die jetzt auch bei Maskenpflicht etc. gebracht werden.
Das sind immer wieder so Dinge, die immer wiederkehren und die man wahrscheinlich einfach so aus den Leuten nicht so ohne Weiteres herausbekommt.
Sprich, es dauert einfach seine Zeit.
Aber in dem Moment, wo sich Leute dann eben auch in ihrem Freiraum, Freiheiten oder einfach nur in ihrem eingespielten Way of Life,
von dem sie sich selber, wo sie keine Bereitschaft sehen oder diese Verantwortung für andere so spüren
und mehr so ichorientiert unterwegs sind, dann nehmen sie natürlich auch schnell Leute, die eben sagen,
ja, du musst jetzt mal deinen Lebenswandel ändern, schnell auch mal als Feinde wahr.
Und dann kommt man doch schon so ein bisschen in so eine Zielscheibe.
Aber ist sozusagen noch nicht so weit bei dir?
Nein, ist noch nicht so weit.
Kommt noch wahrscheinlich.
Vielleicht.
Ja, aber …
Aber andere werden das doch sicherlich in irgendeiner Form schon erfahren haben.
Garantiert und da brauchst du einerseits, glaube ich, ein dickes Fell, um das so ein bisschen …
Ich stelle mir das immer so vor wie so einen Erpel, der im Regen steht und das Gefieder ist schön eingefettet,
so dass der Regen schön abperlt, das brauchst du, Erpelfedern, Entenfedern.
Und ansonsten kannst du einfach nur versuchen, dass das, was du sagst und was du erzählst,
dass das Hand und Fuß hat, und zwar wissenschaftlich betrachtet genau der Stand ist, bei dem wir jetzt sind.
Es bringt ja nichts, die Augen davor zu verschließen.
Also ich meine, klar ist es wichtig, dass wir Arbeitsplätze auch haben in der Industrie
und dass das so gut wie möglich erhalten bleibt, weil jeder Mensch, der seinen Job verliert,
da hängt ja ganz viel dran und da darf man nicht so drüber hinweg wischen.
Das ist einfach auch wichtig, dass man da auch die Menschen sieht.
Aber wenn wir keinen Ort mehr haben, an dem wir leben können, dann hilft dir auch dein Job nicht mehr viel.
Und das ist ganz wichtig.
Ja, das ist definitiv ein Faktor, man kann dann halt mit der Welt, wenn sie nicht mehr so existiert,
dann auch nicht mehr so sehr viel anfangen, kann man auch nicht mehr SUV fahren.
Nein, das ist dann schwierig.
Das ist total schwierig.
Vor allem, wenn alles überschwemmt ist, gut das sind Geländewagen, aber im Gelände sind die ja nicht so wirklich geländegängig,
das ist ja das Problem.
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Ja, bist du optimistisch, ob wir jetzt gerade eher einen Trend zur Verdummung sehen
oder ob das nur so eine Sinuswelle ist und sich eigentlich alles gerade schon wieder parallel verbessert?
Ja, es ist schwierig.
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel einfach mal so ein Stichwort, flache Erde, wenn ich sehe,
wieviele Leute tatsächlich ernsthaft sagen, naja nein, natürlich ist die Erde flach
und alles, was man da so erzählt bekommt, ist eine große Verschwörung.
Finde ich schon hart und dann fange ich schon manchmal an zu zweifeln,
ob wir schon den Ausschlag des Pendels erreicht haben und wieder in eine Richtung uns bewegen,
die vernünftiger ist oder ob wir diese Verschwörungs- und …
Wobei das ja auch das totale Extrem ist.
Ja, ist ein Extrem.
Ja, also das sind so Leute, die offensichtlich ja nicht belehrbar sind.
Ich hatte mal eine interessante Analyse gesehen, als es in den USA mit diesem auch wirklich unfassbar absurden QAnon Verschwörungsblog losging,
da hatte das nämlich den interessanten Effekt, dass auf einmal die ganze Nachfrage nach Flat-Earth-Videos,
die in den Jahren davor ja so durch die Decke gegangen ist, auf einmal wieder stark absank.
Und das mag nur ein Indikator sein, ich fand das allerdings relativ einleuchtend diese Sichtweise,
dass es einfach eine Gruppe von Leuten gibt, die durch was auch immer in ihrem Leben auf so eine bestimmte Art und Weise so verhärmt sind,
dass sie geradezu manisch irgendeinem Kult sich anschließen und da irgendwie reininvestieren,
obwohl sie eigentlich wissen, dass das Unsinn ist, aber dadurch dass sie in der Lage sind,
andere Leute da auch noch mit reinzuziehen und dann innerhalb dieser Szene dann schnell zu irgendwelchen Königen aufsteigen,
weil sie ja sozusagen durch den ganzen Unsinn, den sie dann aufeinander türmen,
von den anderen Leuten noch angehimmelt werden, die dann auf Konferenzen irgendwie groß belobt werden etc.,
so dass es eigentlich nur so ein Wettbewerb ist, den maximalen Unsinn zu bekommen,
um dort irgendwie eine gewisse Anerkennung zu bekommen.
Und man wird akzeptiert dadurch, dass man bereit ist, quasi sein Gehirn an der Garderobe abzugeben
und diesen ganzen Quatsch zu glauben und dann war halt QAnon dann einfach der nächste Schritt, wo alle hingerannt sind.
Du meinst, es ist so eine Art Spiel, das sich dann verselbständigt und dann auf einmal ernst wird,
weil manche Leute gar nicht mehr sehen, dass es als Spiel angefangen hat?
Ja, es wird dann halt einfach, genau, oder sie wissen es vielleicht unterschwellig schon so,
blenden es aber irgendwie komplett aus, weil sie ja sehr viel mehr soziales Einkommen davon haben,
in dieser Bubble zu bleiben und da so eine Anerkennung zu bekommen, die sie vielleicht in ihrem sonstigen Leben,
mit dem was sie erreicht oder nicht erreicht haben, das in der Form so nicht ausgezahlt bekommen.
Also das kann schon sein, dass das sozusagen auch nur so der Schaum ist, der auf den Wellen treibt,
aber einfach eine bestimmte Menge so nicht überschreitet.
Ja, ich hoffe auch, du hast hoffentlich recht, das stimmt natürlich.
Aber auf der anderen Seite sieht man ja auch, dass jetzt bei der Bundestagswahl,
es ist ja klar, wenn wir so weitermachen wie bisher, dann machen wir nicht mehr lange so weiter wie bisher
und das wird richtig teuer.
Und du hast dann auch die Frage, okay welche Prioritäten setze ich?
Ist meine Priorität eher in Klimaschutz und Schutz unserer Lebensbedingungen?
Oder sehe ich Prioritäten eher in dem Schutz von alten Industrien, die vielleicht gar nicht mehr so zeitgemäß sind?
Und da muss man sich dann entscheiden, welchen Weg möchte man gehen.
Und welcher Weg verspricht den größten Erfolg.
Die einen sehen eben wirtschaftlich diesen Weg als erfolgversprechend an und die anderen eben diesen konservativen,
also sprich im Bewahrenden oder zumindest den Weg, den wir jetzt eingeschlagen haben, den abzubrechen
und mal neue Wege zu gehen als erfolgversprechend an und da muss man sich, glaube ich, dann entscheiden,
wohin tendiere ich eher, eher dieses wirtschaftliche oder eher das umweltmäßige.
Das ist die individuelle Entscheidung.
Genau, das ist die individuelle Entscheidung, nach der wählt man dann und die, die gewählt worden sind,
die setzen halt den Rahmen, an dem sich alle anderen orientieren, um dann eventuell dieses Klimaziel,
was wir uns gegeben haben, auch zu erreichen.
Weil das ist ja das irrwitzige, natürlich gibt es viele Leute, die individuell sich entschieden haben,
ich versuche so wenig Müll wie möglich zu machen.
Ich versuche so CO2-neutral wie möglich zu leben, aber leider macht das ja keinen Unterschied,
wenn nur du das machst oder wenn wir beide das machen.
Die großen CO2-Verursacher die müssen das halt auch machen und die machen das aber,
die richten sich einfach nach den gesetzlichen Vorgaben.
Und wenn die so sind, dass sie das so weitermachen können wie bisher, natürlich da haben die überhaupt keine Motivation, das zu ändern.
Bzw. sie haben sogar eine Motivation das nicht zu ändern, weil solange die anderen das ja auch noch machen dürfen
und sich dadurch einen Vorteil verschaffen können, habe ich ja gar keine andere Wahl, im wirtschaftlichen Zwang das anders zu leben.
Ich werde nie vergessen, wir waren irgendwie 17, zwölfte Klasse und sind zu dem Onkel von einem Freund nach Nürnberg gefahren,
weil die da hinziehen wollten und so und der hatte eine Pumpenfabrik.
Und wir sind dann zu ihm ins Büro und er war so der Chef dieser Fabrik.
Pumpenkönig.
Und hat uns gefragt, so was denkt ihr, warum machen wir das alles hier?
Und wir so mit 17 irgendwie ganz idealistisch, ja um Arbeitsplätze zu schaffen,
um irgendwie Leuten Geld und Leute ernähren zu können.
Wir hatten alle möglichen hehren Ideen im Kopf und er so, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich sage euch, warum wir das machen, wir wollen Geld verdienen.
Ja, klar natürlich, er will einfach Pumpen verkaufen und Geld verdienen und das war es.
Und alles andere hat ihn nicht so interessiert.
So ist es, wenn du ein Business hast, du willst einfach Geld verdienen, um dich zu ernähren und vielleicht auch noch deine anderen Leute zu ernähren,
aber das ist das A und O.
Und wie du das dann machst, das regeln die Rahmenbedingungen und die werden halt von der Politik gemacht.
Und das ist das wichtigste und wenn da sich nichts ändert, dann werden sich die Firmen auch nicht ändern.
Also so freiwillige Selbstverpflichtungen von denen halte ich nicht viel.
Ja, das liebe Geld.
Haben wir denn eine Chance oder wie weit sind wir denn davon entfernt oder haben wir sie vielleicht,
die sogenannte Wissensgesellschaft, die wirklich in der Lage ist, auf Basis des erlernten Wissens die richtigen Entscheidungen für sich zu fällen?
Sind wir da auf dem Weg dahin, sind wir da eigentlich schon und merken es bloß gerade nicht
oder verlassen wir den Pfad?
Ich glaube, das ist so das, was sich viele fragen.
Ich glaube, im Großen und Ganzen sind wir schon auf einem guten Weg.
Wir dürfen halt nur nicht unseren Twitterstream verwechseln mit dem echten Leben.
Also da ist auch sehr viel False Balance in unseren sozialen Netzwerken.
Keine Ahnung warum, aber ich glaube nicht, dass alle immer so rumkrakelen, wie es da der Fall ist.
Ich glaube, wenn man sich so von Angesicht zu Angesicht trifft und unterhält, ist es ein ganz anderer Umgangston
als den, den man so von den sozialen Netzwerken kennt.
Und da muss man sich immer wieder dran erinnern.
Das Leben ist nicht das, was da so online stattfindet.
Also das Leben und das Zwischenmenschliche ist ganz anders.
Das Leben ist eigentlich wie ein Podcast.
Ja.
Schön, dass du hier hingekommen bist.
Ich finde es auch ganz toll.
Ralph, vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Danke dir.
Und ja das war die neue Folge von Forschergeist und ich hoffe sehr bald auf weitere Folgen.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.